So, weiter gehts, muss ja mal was ordentliches bei rauskommen, gestern sind wir nicht fertig
geworden, ob wir fertig werden weiß ich nicht, ich vermute mal nicht, aber weiter gehts.
Erstmal warten bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass der Stream online ist, wobei hat Twitch, Twitch
ist schneller geworden in letzter Zeit, guck mal ich bin jetzt genau eine Minute 40 on und
Twitch hat's kapiert, hat schon 40 Leuten Bescheid gesagt, ich mein es kann natürlich
auch sein, dass ihr seit gestern hier die Abobox offen habt, aber das bezweifle ich
ehrlich gesagt.
Instant, vielleicht sind einfach nicht so viele große Streamer online und deswegen gehen
die Notifications schneller oder Twitch hat Upgraded, man weiß es nicht.
Ja, Twitch hat's mitbekommen, ja das ist wenn du die Seite nicht refreshed hast, sobald
du die Seite refreshst ist wieder alles ok, Sekunde, lasst mich mal kurz checken ob Teams
mit der rumgesponnen hat, wo ist das Soundsettings, wer nämlich denkt im Volume Mixer ist das
Mikrofon, der liegt falsch, this device is currently in use, oh mein Gott, nein, wirklich,
das ist ja, was Windows mir da für geile Sachen mitteilen hätte ich ja gar nicht mit
gerechnet, also ich mein es könnte ja sein, dass ich gerade mit dem Mikrofon rede und
gar nicht weiß, was ich gerade mache, ja gut, das hat schon seinen Sinn, weil sie wollen
einen jetzt darauf hinweisen, dass es sein kann, dass manche Anwendungen kaputt gehen,
aber trotzdem.
Egal, ich werde immer noch nicht warm mit Windows 11, ganz ehrlich, Windows 11 ist einfach
nur übelster Sack, aber ich komm nicht dran vorbei, Leute bevor wir heute anfangen, bevor
wir heute anfangen, sonst machen wir das nämlich nie, sonst machen wir das nie und ich hab's
mir noch nicht angeguckt, ehrlich, ich hab's mir noch nicht angeguckt, ich hab nur die
ersten 5 Sekunden gesehen, wo er sagt, er hat ein Video in seiner Empfehlung oder sowas
in der Richtung, weil wenn wir das heute nicht gucken, dann gucken wir es nie und ihr kennt
mich, ich vergammel manchmal auch so so Dinger und dann machen wir es nie, wir müssen heute
reacten auf die Reaction, so wie man das im Influencer Game macht, wir haben es leider
nur, Leute, wir haben es leider nur, was heißt wir, ihr gar nicht, aber klingt netter, wenn
ich sage wir, wir haben es nur in zweitklassische Reaktionen geschafft, hast schon gesehen,
so werden große deutsche YouTuber gehackt, naja gut, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, ob das diese Art und Weise ist, wie die Leute gehackt werden,
ich hab's ja auch mal offen gelassen im Video, die meisten, die wahrscheinlich, also von
den großen Channels, die meisten werden wahrscheinlich über irgendwelche Viren Trojaner, die sich
eingefangen haben, mit geklauten Cookies oder kompletter Remote-Fernsteuerung des Rechners
oder sowas gehackt, aber möglich ist das auch, was ich da gezeigt hab und es war auf
jeden Fall dafür gedacht, was bei mir auf dem Rechner einzuschleusen, so viel ist sicher.
Gucken wir gleich, ich lese mal ein bisschen, ich lese mal ein bisschen die Kommentare
durch, bevor wir uns das Video angucken, dann ist vielleicht auch der Stream auf Twitch
richtig angelaufen, also zeig mal, was schreiben die Leute denn hier, gibt es sowas wie ein
Training Tool, um eine Oma zu trainieren, ja, das ist ganz einfach, wisst ihr, wie das
Training Tool heißt, der Oma einfach in Ubuntu installieren, bei der Oma geht das tatsächlich,
weil die Oma macht nix außer einen Browser auf und E-Mails auf, wenn, wenn die Oma natürlich
ein paar ausgefallenere Sachen benutzt, dann könnte es sein, dass das keine gute Idee
ist, aber wenn die Oma wirklich nur einen Browser benutzt, da drin ein bisschen YouTube
guckt oder vielleicht mal eine eine andere E-Mail schreibt, Instant Messenger bekommt,
dann Linux draufhauen oder du kannst der Oma auch ein Tablet geben, wobei Tablet natürlich
auch nicht ganz ohne ist, musst du anpassen für ältere Leute, ich habe meiner Mutter
auch die Schriftgröße irgendwie auf 250% oder so gestellt mittlerweile, auf Tablet
oder auf dem Handy, überall, überall, ich habe da sogar ein iPhone 11 was glaube ich
gekauft, weil die hatte vorher nur ein iPhone SE, da habe ich extra ein iPhone 11 gekauft,
dass er was sieht und die wollte nicht, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, es gibt Leute, die sind
einem böse, wenn man 800 Euro für sie ausgibt, kann man sich nicht vorstellen oder, die hat
ein iPhone SE gehabt und hat die ganze Zeit erzählt, sie sieht da so schlecht was drauf
und habe ich gesagt, ja komm, das können wir kaufen, ein größeres ist doch kein Problem
und da hat sie sich tausend Ausreden ausgedacht, nein, nein, das ist ja noch gut, das können
wir doch jetzt nicht wegschmeißen, das neue passt gar nicht in die Tasche, die hat wieder
Schiss gehabt, so wie das halt ist, die hat wieder Schiss gehabt, dass das neue sich so
viel geändert hat, dass man sich wieder umgewöhnen muss und so was, dann habe ich ihr einfach
ein iPhone gekauft, weil ich wusste, ich wusste, wenn ich das da habe, dann nimmt sie es,
weil die will ja kein neues wegschmeißen, ja, ich habe einfach ein neues iPhone gekauft,
sagt ihr Mama hast es und seitdem verwendet ihr das auch und da habe ich auch die Schrift
auf 250%, 250% gedreht, jetzt erkennt sie ordentlich was drauf, ja, aber sie wollte
erst nicht, sie wollte erst nicht, da hat sie wirklich beschwert, so nach dem Motto,
wie, was soll das, was erlaubt er sich 800 Euro für mich auszugeben, kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen, dass Leute gibt, die sich darüber beschweren oder, so, also zeig mal
hier, was schreiben denn die Leute Spannendes, übrigens, wenn wir hier fertig sind mit Influencer
Reaction Game, dann machen wir mit unserer White People Happy VM weiter, da steht heute
einiges an, ich habe mir ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben, wir müssen Icons einfügen,
wir müssen noch die wichtigsten Sachen installieren, wir probieren mal You Launcher aus, was gestern
jemand vorgeschlagen hat, ich habe ein richtig cooles Feature im Terminal gefunden, was
ich euch zeigen will, Maus Theme müssen wir noch ändern, die Statusleiste müssen wir
endlich mal ordentlich machen, dass sie nicht so billig aussieht und ein paar andere Sachen,
gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier schauen, was da,
was im Reaction Game so los ist. Auf welche dummen Fragen kann ich mich morgen
bei dem IHK Fachgespräch einstellen, was hast du für ein Abschlussprojekt, was hast
du für ein Abschlussprojekt, wie heißt dein Abschlussprojekt, warst du das mit dem VPN,
der das gleiche gemacht hat wie ich, fast das gleiche wie ich, also es kommt auf dein Projekt,
dann sag mal wie dein Projekt heißt, also du kannst dich, wenn nichts geht, stell dich
auf blöde Fragen zu Subnetting und zu Osimodell ein, wenn dir nichts einfällt, dann kommt
das Osimodell um die Ecke. Leute, wer kennt die Osilayer aus dem Kopf,
ich, ich, ich nicht, physical, session, nee, Moment, was ist das, please do, ok, physical
data, please do not throw salami pizza away, physical data, network, transport, session,
irgendwann kommt application, frag mich nicht, ja, wer weiß ich auch nicht, wer weiß ich
auch nicht, session, presentation, ach ja, und dann, und dann kommt irgendwann application,
gibt es dein Desktop Bild irgendwo, nein, das haben wir AI upscaled, wisst ihr was ich
mir, ja Tiska, wir haben den AI, AI upscaled, den Wallpaper, soll ich euch das hochladen
irgendwo, den Wallpaper, kann ich machen, glaubt euch, Leute, und wisst ihr was ich
mach, ich geb, ich geb ein bisschen Geld aus, für euch, ja, und zwar, ich mache das was
letztens jemand im Stream vorgeschlagen hat, ich lasse mir von einem Grafikbearbeitungs-Dude,
den ich kenne, Wallpaper-Versionen erstellen, so ungefähr, ich, ich, ich würde mal sagen
so 8, 8 verschiedene, dass der Pepo euch über den Tag begleiten kann, es gibt dann
quasi den Pepo Happy morgens, dann ist der Himmel noch dunkel und ein paar Sterne am
Himmel, und der Pepo hat so eine Schlafmütze auf, dann gibt es das nächste Bild, da ist
er gerade am Frühstücken oder sowas, sowas in der Richtung, ja, dann irgendwie mittags
scheint, mittags scheint die Sonne, da sitzt er am Rechner und arbeitet, da kriegt er hier
irgendwie so ein Keyboard davor, wir machen so einen, wir machen so einen, White Pepo
Happy Background, der einen den Tag über, ja, wobei das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
schwierig ist, das könnte wahrscheinlich sogar der Chainlaw machen, wenn er nachher
da ist, das glaubt ihr, das ist nicht schwer, aber ich, ich gebe das jemand, ich gebe das
jemand, der dann, den man auch dafür bezahlen muss, ja, alles klar, und dann, dann kriegt
er auch, der kriegt auch die Backgrounds, ok, ähm, Projekt ist eine Webseite, die Cut-Dateien
mit 3D, oh, Moment, sowas kompliziertes macht bei einem Abschlussprojekt, wobei ist das
kompliziert, da gibt es auch bestimmt fertige Libraries, aber, ja, ok, dann, dann kann
ich dir nicht sagen, was sie dich fragen, ich meine, ich fände wahrscheinlich sehr
sicher was zu, zu JavaScript, HTML, CSS-Fragen, weil das ist ja eine Webseite, und eventuell
fragen sie dich natürlich auch zu Osimodell, weil immerhin müssen die Daten ja zu dir
hinkommen, und, und deine Requests zum Server, oh, sie fragen, genau, sie fragen sie dich
immer, oh, sie kommt immer dran, so, ich wollte mal kurz ein bisschen in die Kommentare gucken,
was, was haben denn die Leute hier unter dem Video so geschrieben, also, zeig mal her,
also, also, ich hab alles verstanden, lull, lull, lull, aha, ja, das garantiert, garantiert
gibt es Leute, die so blöd sind, da hat er recht, ja, im Zweifelsfall fragen die dich
sogar ein bisschen BWL Zeug morgen auf der Abschlussprüfung, wenn du Pech hast, weil
die IHK ist ja immer noch der Meinung, man kann das nicht oft genug sagen, ich find es
dumm, aber die IHK sieht das so, und letztendlich ist es nicht wichtig, was ich zu sage, sondern
was die IHK zu sagen, die IHK sagt, dass der Fachinformatiker zur Hälfte ein Kaufmann
ist, ich hab mit BWL, ihr wisst, ich hab ja mal sowas in der Richtung versucht zu lernen,
also ich stehe ja da komplett auf Kriegsfuß mit, einzige, was ich mir gemerkt hab, ist,
dass man linear oder degressiv abschreiben kann und so ein Shit, und ich kann auch noch
eine Buchhalternase malen, das wars aber so ziemlich alles, was ich aus meinem BWL, äh,
aus meinem BWL, ja, lebend mitgenommen hab, aber das kann sein, der Fachinformatiker ist
ein halber Kaufmann lauter IHK, was richtig dumm ist, na ein bisschen Projektbezug brauchen
die schon, aber den Projektbezug kannst du ja eigentlich zu nahe zu allem herstellen,
sowas wie tolle Layer 3 Switche, ich sag nix, ihr kennt mich, wenn es um das Thema Layer
3 Switche geht, da kann ich jetzt ne halbe Stunde erzählen, so das war was, das ist doch
die Rimworld Musik im Hintergrund, das ist richtig, das hat er gut erkannt, ok ich hab
angeblich Stefan Rap Vibes, ich bin mal gespannt, ich bin mal gespannt, so also wir gucken uns
das Video jetzt mal an, 28 Minuten, na gut, das ist mal ein Video, mein Video ist lang
und er reagiert drauf, das ist noch länger, ihr wisst, wenn ich auf so ein Video reagiert
hätte, im Original, da hätt ich wahrscheinlich 2 Stunden zu erzählen, aber ich lass es jetzt
einfach mal durchlaufen, ok, ich muss kurz die Musik ausmachen, also schauen wir uns
das ganze mal an, ok ich gebe zu, die Überschrift war vielleicht ein bisschen heftig, aber so
läuft das halt auf YouTube heute, ich glaube ich kenn den YouTuber, deswegen würd ich
das einfach mal anschauen und hoffen, dass da was bisschen konkreteres zu tun kommt,
das sind 20 Minuten Videos von Max FPS, den guck ich immer mal, den guck ich immer mal,
wenn es um IT Sachen geht und der hat dazu auch ein Video gemacht und da würd ich eher
mal reingehen, ah das ist gekuttet, das ist gekuttet oder, das ist bestimmt ein bisschen
gekuttet, das ist gut, dann dauert das nicht so lange, Reactception, ja ja, wir reacten
jetzt auf jemanden, der auf mein Video reactet, aber das ist nichts Leute, das ist nichts,
was ansonsten im deutschsprachigen YouTube Raum abgeht, da geht alles, da kommt dann
irgendwie einer, da kommt dann Unge, macht Ansage an ApoRed, ich hab keine Ahnung ob
da sowas hier gemacht hat, darauf reagiert dann Inscope, das ganze guckt sich Montana
Black an und am Ende reactet Unge nochmal auf seine Ansprache, wo die anderen reactet
haben und wenn du Pech hast, ganz am Ende nimmt dann ApoRed nochmal Stellung und das
ganze geht von vorne los, also das ist wirklich Reactception angesagt auf YouTube, da ist
das hier, das ist ein Recursive React, da ist das hier noch wirklich wirklich harmlos,
dass wir auf jemanden reacten, der auf mich reactet, auf gehts, das stimmt, oh ein Cut,
ein echter Copyright Strike zu bekommen und das will man eigentlich nicht haben, das
heißt, sobald man sowas hier im E-Mail Postfach hat, dann denkt man sich, oh fuck, was ist
denn jetzt los, das hier, was ihr hier seht, ist mein Business E-Mail Postfach, ich hab
das jetzt extra so eingestellt, dass man sonst nichts sieht, außer diese E-Mail, die
ich gestern bekommen hab und man denkt sich erstmal, oh scheiße, was ist da los, da hab
ich auch erstmal blöd geguckt und so ein bisschen Panik kriegt man dabei schon und
ich kann euch sagen, by the way, bevor wir wirklich ins Detail gehen, das ist Absicht,
Panik ist einfach dazu da oder was, das ist ein bisschen wie beim Enkeltrick, man versucht
die Leute zu Fehlern zu verleiten und das geht mit Panik einfach gut, weil wer in Panik
ist, denkt nicht nach, klickt vielleicht auf Sachen, woran ich draufklicken sollte.
Bin ich selbst laut genug jetzt, weil mit Reaction in Reaction hab ich nicht so die
Erfahrung und ich bin mal 5 Minuten in mich gegangen, ich klick nicht einfach random
irgendwelche Sachen an, zumindest hab ich die E-Mail aufgemacht, hab mir gedacht, hm,
das wäre jetzt hier so ne Phishing-Sache. Richtig. Richtig. Das hat er gut erkannt.
Und dann bin ich zum Schluss gekommen, das ist sicher wohl um einen gezielten Angriff,
wobei ob der Angriff... Also ob man mich in meinem Stream versteht, wie ich im Original
geredet habe. Ich war mal ein Stückchen lauter. Auf mich ist oder allgemein, muss man mal gucken,
was wir da jetzt noch rauskriegen gleich, um einen Angriff. Kommt es nur mir vor oder
hören sich Max sehr unterschiedlich an. Das liegt daran, weil ich ein fauler Sack bin
und in meinem Streaming Setup mein Headset auf hab und nicht mein ordentliches Mikrofon verwendet.
Er macht das richtig, er verwendet ein ordentliches Mikrofon, auch wenn er streamt. Ich bin aber zu
faul und ich spring immer zu viel vom PC rum, wenn ich am Streamen bin. Also hin und her wackeln,
springen nicht, ihr wisst, wie ich das meine. Deswegen hab ich mein Headset auf und mein
Headset hört sich halt nicht so gut an wie mein normales Mikrofon. Dazu kommt, dass ich hier auch
noch eine Noise Gate drinne habe und ein bisschen Filter. Aber es ist so viel unterschiedlich,
wird es sich wahrscheinlich nicht anhalten. Und außerdem, was ich auch gemerkt hab,
was ich auch unterschiedlich anhöre ist, je nachdem wann ich das aufnehme, das hab ich glaube ich
irgendwann vormittags oder so aufgenommen und abends. Ich hör mich unterschiedlich an, ob ich
morgens aufnehme oder mittags. Egal, weiter. Auf meinen YouTube Channel oder auf mich handelt,
aber sehr wahrscheinlich auf meinen YouTube Channel. Und der Sache muss ich natürlich mal
ein bisschen nachgehen. Deshalb würde ich sagen, let's go, wir gucken uns das Ganze mal zusammen
an. Sehr interessant, dass er das mal macht. Also jetzt sind ja schon mehrere Kanäle tops
gegangen. Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Das ist JP Performance, dann ist Hand of Blood, dann sind
noch ein paar andere. Ich mein, den M-Core hat es vor einer ganzen Weile mal erwischt. Julian Bam
mit 28 Faktor-Authentifizierung hat es erwischt. Ja, ich reakte auf eine Reaktion auf mich, korrekt.
Kaubi, danke schön für den Zap. Schon vor längerer Zeit ein bisschen abgegriffen worden,
Julian Bam. Ja. Längere Zeit zurück und ja. War nicht ApoRed auch? War da nicht auch mal was?
Das ist ein Video. Schreibt jemand, Vorsicht, wir sehen grad deine E-Mails. Oh nein. Bro. Bro.
Bro. Und selbst wenn, wo wäre das Problem? Vor allem, weil das sicherlich seine E-Mail ist.
Was ich schon rausbekommen habe. Und übrigens, nicht nachmachen an der Stelle. Vorsicht,
deine E-Mails sind gerade im Stream zu sehen. Vorsicht, sei gewarnt. Er muss ich gleich noch
mal sagen, schon gar nicht unter Windows, versaut euch euren Rechner nicht. Wenn man nicht aufpasst,
führt man recht schnell was aus. Ich muss mich jetzt zusammenreißen. Ich gebe mir gerne,
wenn ich meine eigenen Videos höre, gebe ich mir selbst gerne recht. Das klingt aber unglaublich
bescheuert, wenn ich mich selbst höre und die ganze Zeit sage, ja, so ist es, so ist es. Deswegen
halte ich die Klampe. Ich werde ja malwareverseucht. Macht das nicht? Schon gar nicht. Genau. Ich bin
da voll bei Max, denn das beste Antivirus ist dein Verstand. Richtig. Es gibt keinen effizienteren
Schutz vor Viren und vor Übergriffen und vor komischen. Generell Gehirn ist immer gut. Und
Spamware als dein Verstand. Ich habe mal eine Frage. Ich kenne so seinen Hintergrund nicht. Hat
er irgendwas mit Technik am Hut? Wisst ihr das? Guckt jemand öfters? Ich kenne ihn vom Namen her,
aber ich hatte nie was mit ihm zu tun, geschweige denn, dass ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich
regel hatte. Okay, dann weiß er wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen, um was geht. Und dann auch ohne
Netzwerk am besten abgeschirmt mit dem Linux ohne Zugriff auf irgendwelche. Er hat auch mal
Physi gelernt. Physi Gang am Start. Nur mal so jetzt nicht. Also auch wenn man hier irgendwelche
URL sieht, wo man irgendwelche Sachen runterladen kann, lasst es bleiben. Guckt mir einfach lieber
zu dabei. Okay. Und wenn euch mein Content gefällt. Aber wo ist der laut? Ich glaube Max
streamt auch auf Twitch. Ja, das ist richtig. Ich stream auch auf Twitch. Falls ihr den mal live
sehen wollt. Er streamt auch auf Twitch. Ich bin heute nicht auf Twitch, weil wir heute Multistream
machen. Aber ich glaube, Max streamt auch auf Twitch. Das ist korrekt. Da heißt er aber Wubblors.
Wenn ihr den Abo drückt, falls ihr das nicht schon gemacht habt, dann sieht man sich hier
demnächst wahrscheinlich auch öfters. Ich verteile den Link danach. Wie immer. Normal würde ich
mir jetzt natürlich den Header angucken, dieser E-Mail. Aber ich kenne Adobe Sign. Adobe Sign ist
ein Service von, ja da streiten sich ja die Geistern, ob man jetzt Adobe oder wie auch immer
ausspricht. Das ist ein Service von Adobe, wie man digital Verträge unterschreiben kann.
Habe ich selber schon öfters benutzt für Sponsorings und sonst was. War das jetzt bei mir gerade oder bei
ihm im Stream? Danke schön für den Sub. Der Chat ist im Weg. Ah Moment, Moment, ich hab
Interesse. Der Chat ist im Weg. Machen wir kurz den Chat aus, sonst funktioniert das überhaupt nicht. Und erinnert mich dran, dass ich den Chat wieder
anmache. Die dafür recht beliebt sind. Das heißt, die E-Mail an sich, die müssen wir nicht untersuchen.
Ich habe mir das auch schon angeguckt. Wir können hier mal. Jetzt kommt der richtige Hacker-Kram hier.
Auf Adobe Sign, aber da wird man sehen, da ist nichts Verdächtiges dran. Wenn man Google-Suche
danach macht, stellt man auch fest, ja das ist wirklich ein Domain von Adobe und hier sieht man es auch.
Also, da ist nichts Suspekt oder Sass, wie man ho- Das ist ja merkwürdig, aber wenn die von Adobe Sign
direkt kommt? Vorzusehen. Die E-Mail ist echt, aber es gibt trotzdem- Ja, die kommt von Adobe Sign direkt. Jeder
kann auf der Welt, jeder auf der Welt kann Adobe Sign verwenden, auch für Scam. Deswegen sagt es
gar nichts drüber aus. Also Leute, ich könnte jetzt den übelsten Scam verteilen, aber über Adobe Sign.
Das sind ein paar Sachen, die sehr merkwürdig sind an der ganzen E-Mail. Das erste ist, es ging an die
falsche E-Mail-Adresse. Es ging nämlich an meine Business E-Mail-Adresse und nicht an die YouTube
E-Mail-Adresse. YouTube E-Mail-Adresse kennt nämlich gar keiner. Das ist meine Business E-Mail-Adresse.
An der Stelle noch mal angemerkt, bitte Leute, seht davon ab, mir an die Business E-Mail-Adresse,
auch wenn man die jetzt hier im Video sieht. Da ist es, da ist es. Über Ausbildung, irgendwelche
Fragen, IT-Projekte oder sonst was in der Richtung. Das ist wirklich nur für Business-Anfragen
gedacht. Ich war mal kurz ein bisschen vor, mein Intro-Gelaber brauchen wir ja nicht.
Er klingt ein bisschen wie eine IT-Stefan-Rab-Version. Auf Twitter oder irgendwo.
Habe ich schon öfters jetzt gehört, aber gut. Warum nicht? Schreib bitte nicht an diese
Business E-Mail-Adresse. Ich werde darauf nicht antworten und ich kann darauf nicht.
Wenn irgendwelche Strikes sind, dann sieht man die normalerweise auf YouTube und eigentlich
kommen diese E-Mails auch nicht von Adobe Sign, sondern eben von YouTube, die dir sagen wollen,
Achtung, da hat irgendjemand Copyright-Sachen gegen dich. Findet ihr nicht? Findet ihr nicht?
Ja gut, dann finde ich das alleine. Okay, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Und aber mal ehrlich, so oft. Kennste, kennste, ist doch nicht Stefan
Raab. Kennste, kennste, ist Mario Bart. Ist deutlich unlustiger als Stefan Raab.
Ich habe jetzt auch keine Copyright-Strikes oder Reports und deswegen weiß da auch nicht jeder
sofort, wo er genau drauf gucken muss. Ich auch nicht. Mein letzter Copyright-Strike ist zum Glück
weg, war damals schon nicht gerechtfertigt und ist schon so lange her. Keine Ahnung,
wie die E-Mails heute aussehen. Also Leute, ich finde Stefan Raab, also zumindest die
Sendung von früher, fand ich deutlich lustiger als Mario Bart. Er weiß, vielleicht hat sich ja
was geändert und die E-Mail selbst, wie gesagt, die sieht echt aus. Okay Max, jetzt geht's los hier.
Punkt Company, die gibt es. Punkt Company ist eine echte Top-Level-Domain. Es gibt ja mittlerweile
alle möglichen Top-Level-Domains und Punkt Company ist eine davon. Wirklich viel weiter
bringt uns das allerdings nicht. Domain-Registrar verwenden sie Namecheap. Klingt jetzt erstmal
vielleicht ein bisschen nach Scam, ist aber kein Scam. Ich verwende selbst für einige Domains
Namecheap. Da ist überhaupt nichts verdächtiges dran. Ich habe sogar mittlerweile bei ganz vielen
Domain-Registrars irgendwelche sinnlosen Domains, weil ich gerade dabei bin, so einen Check zu
programmieren, wo man das Ablaufdatum von Domains überwachen kann. Und da brauche ich ein paar
Billigh Domains, ein paar Billigh Hostern, um zu gucken, ob das funktioniert. Der versteht nur
Bahnhof, glaube ich nicht, also oder weiß nicht. Ich habe den Eindruck, er erfasst das eigentlich
ganz gut. Zumal irgendjemand im Chat geschrieben hat, dass er auch irgendwie früher, im früheren
Leben mal so ein bisschen Technik-Background hatte. Denke schon, dass damit kommt. Und dass man die Details nicht sieht, ist auch
mittlerweile normal. Eine interessante Sache vielleicht noch ist, dass die Cloudflash... Super
interessant, Alter, dass er das da einfach mal erklärt....als DNS verwenden. Also sprich, die Domain ist bei
Namecheap... Was bezahlst du im Jahr für eine Domain zwischen 5 und 12 Euro, je nachdem, was
es für eine Domain ist? Aber sie selbst verwenden als... Striker, danke schön für den Zap. Nicht von Namecheap, sondern
nicht von Cloudflare. Ist aber auch gar nichts verdächtiges, weil das Ganze mache ich auch. Cloudflare hat ein
super... Korrekt ist eine Reaktion auf eine Reaktion....und wird in nahezu jedem Tool mit Cloudflare...
Wie viel ich für alle Domains zusammen bezahle? Ach, lass es mal 100 Euro sein. So viel ist das nicht im
Jahr....Zertifikate, Let's Encrypt... Darum ist auch immer, wenn Cloudflare down ist, gleichzeitig
alles down. Also wenn Cloudflare down ist, dann kommst du wirklich an ganz viele Sachen gar nicht
mehr ran....Zertifikate auszustellen, ist also nichts verdächtiges. Das heißt, die Domain, wenn man drauf geht,
kommt halt keine Seite. Sieht jetzt auch erstmal nicht verdächtig aus. Das heißt, uns bleibt nichts
anderes übrig wie, wir klicken doch einfach mal den Link an. Don't do this at home. Kurze Sache,
niemals einfach so den Link anklicken, auch wenn ihr Norton installiert hat. Ich mache kurz ein
kleines IT-Tutorial. Das Schlimmste ist, und das sagt ihr bitte eurer Mama und euren Papa und eurer Oma,
nur weil ihr ein IT, weil ihr ein Antivirus-Software installiert hat, heißt das nicht, dass man deswegen
überall draufklicken darf. Aber gut, ich bin in meiner Linux-Feier, da passiert nichts. Don't do it.
Und jetzt wird es natürlich schon ein bisschen schwierig. Leute, nicht einfach irgendwelche random Links angucken, um mal zu gucken, was da so drauf ist. Ich habe gesagt...
Max hat recht....macht es nicht aus. So, also was passiert, wenn man das anklickt? Leider nichts mehr.
Gestern kam da noch was, und ich werde euch jetzt mal einen Screenshot zeigen von dem, was da gestern kam, weil mittlerweile wurde das Ganze
cancelt. Wahrscheinlich, weil, ich habe nämlich mal auf Google gesucht mittlerweile, das ist auch was, was ich empfehlen kann.
Bevor ihr irgendwas anklickt, googelt einfach mal ein bisschen danach. Es gibt nämlich mittlerweile schon
Einträge, die ihr jetzt witzigerweise hier nicht mehr findet, aber eben gefunden habt, Google-Logik. Es gibt
mittlerweile Einträge hier vor 15 Stunden von Leuten, denen das auch sehr sass vorgekommen ist, diese E-Mail.
Und es sind sich hier eigentlich alle einig. Scheint hier irgendwie scammy. Scheint hier alles nicht so ganz mit rechten Dingen zuzugehen.
Zumindest ist das Ganze leider cancelt, aber ich zeige euch mal, was gestern aufgegangen ist.
Was mir übrigens jetzt im Nachhinein auffällt, ich habe das Video nicht ganz mit dem richtigen Farbprofil gerendert,
weil im Hintergrund, was ich sage in dem Video, was man aber gar nicht sieht, im Hintergrund hatte das hier so fake Wasserzeichen,
dieses Dokument, dass es noch echter aussieht. Und ich habe das irgendwie mit falschen Settings gerendert,
sodass das Wasserzeichen nicht richtig rauskommt.
We have detected a copyright infringement such a videoclip of background sound belonging to UK music on YouTube video hosting platform.
Ja, das klingt allein schon ein bisschen...
Was? Music copyright designated legal ownership of a music composition or a sound recording.
This ownership includes exclusive rights to retribution. Full infringement report. Please remove infringed third party content to avoid a complaint direct to YouTube.
Also, aber das ist doch schon... Das ist ja übel. Also, das ist halt ein fucking...
Word doc.
Da machst du halt eine Word Datei auf.
Denkt man, denkt man. Ist es gar nicht. Ist es gar nicht.
Es sieht so aus wie ein Word doc, aber wenn man draufklickt, kommt was ganz anderes. Am Ende kommt aber ein Word doc raus.
UK music team?
Hä?
Wenn man hier drauf geklickt hat.
Oder da musst du aber schon richtig AFK sein für, oder?
Das stimmt.
Und zwar, ich blende euch das Ganze mal ein. Ein Dokument, was wahnsinnig wichtig...
Da musst du schon wirklich blöd sein als YouTuber, wenn du das nicht checkst.
...aussieht sogar mit Wasserzeichen und die üblichen Buzzwords sind drinne von Copyright, UK music, YouTube, Copyright, Legal ownership, alles drinne.
Was allerdings schon äußerst verdächtig ist, allerdings anders ist, als man jetzt denkt auf den ersten Blick, dieser Link, der da drinne ist.
Da wird, wenn du auf den Link draufklickst, ich weiß nicht, ob er das gleich zeigt, aber da werden bestimmt die diabolischsten Makros ausgeführt.
Noch gar nicht. Das kommt erst im nächsten Schritt.
Dein Rechner wird, deine Festplatte wird verschlüsselt und du musst zwei Bitcoins bezahlen, damit die dir den Key geben. Weißt du, sowas.
Ich rechne übrigens auch damit, dass das eine entweder ein Crypto Miner ist, bzw. irgendeine Ransomware. Geh ich fest von aus.
Der zweite Teil, das können wir gerade nicht machen, das ist fest geplant, werden wir auch noch machen.
Der Florian hat gerade ein paar andere Probleme, mit denen er kämpfen muss.
YouTube Natur, ja. Und da konnten wir noch nicht aufnehmen.
Copyrights.digital. YouTube blablabla. Report.docx.
Gut, dass so ein Report als Doc verschickt wird, kann ich mir irgendwie vorstellen, mein PDF oder eine Webseite wäre deutlich sinnvoller.
Aber ganz ehrlich, irgendwelche Random Word Dokumente im Internet runterladen und dann öffnen ist schon mal eine äußerst schlechte Idee.
Ganz schlechte Idee.
Dass es wie ein USB Stick finden und den einfach benutzen. Ganz schlechte Idee.
Ja, Noah, danke schön für den Zap.
Wenn du einen USB Stick in einem zerknitterten Umschlag in deinem Briefkasten hast, auf dem steht, wichtige Daten und du steckst den einfach so als schlechte Idee. Einfach nicht machen.
Blöde Idee, richtig.
Leider geht der ganze Link nicht mehr und sollte er gehen, Leute, tippt es nicht ein, probiert es nicht aus.
Ich würde drauf schreiben, wichtig, bitte bei Verlust unbedingt hier zurück geben. Das muss besonders einladend klingen, wenn du so einen USB Stick verlierst.
Alternativ reicht es wahrscheinlich auch, wenn du den gleichen USB Stick mit dem gleichen Inhalt einfach 20 billige AliExpress USB Sticks kaufst und einfach auf dem Parkplatz vom Lidl ausleerst.
Das dauert wahrscheinlich keine halbe Stunde, dann hast du die ersten Remote-Shell-Connections.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal an.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich gehe davon aus, es geht dauerlich lange.
Wenn man da draufklickt, kommt man auf folgende Seite.
Nicht etwa auf ein Wortdokument oder so, wie das ganze aussieht.
Man kommt auf diese Seite hier, sieht im Quellcode so aus, sind 15-16 Zeilen HTML.
Auch total belanglos, eine HTML, also eine PHP-Seite nachgeladen, embedded wird.
Aber wenn man diese Seite aufmacht, dann kommt man auf folgende Seite.
Dann sieht man so einen Fake-Capture, warum die dieses Fake-Capture drinnen haben.
Leute, ich habe ehrlich gesagt absolut keine Ahnung, vielleicht um es zuordnen zu können, wer es ist oder...
Vielleicht einfach um den Eindruck zu erwecken, dass es offiziell ist.
Vielleicht einfach nur, damit es vertrauenserweckender aussieht.
Ich weiß es nicht, zumindest ist das alles nur Fake.
Wenn man das dann eingegeben hat, kommt man zu einem Donut.
Und zwar, was runtergeladen wird, ist ein Zip getarnt als Wortdokument.
Und wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was in diesem Zip drin ist.
Alter, voll wild.
Also, warum die das so kompliziert machen, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Hey, die Dateien habe ich so genannt, Virus.zip.
Das sage ich doch auch gleich, dass ich die Virus.zip genannt habe.
Hier ist dieses Zip, Leute.
Also man sieht schon, das Zip selber ist 46 MB groß, ganz schön groß für einen Report.
Übrigens, die Datei, die man sich runterlädt, die heißt natürlich nicht Virus.zip.
Okay, ich dachte schon, ich dachte schon.
Das habe ich so genannt.
Okay, danke. Ich dachte, das wäre richtig witzig, wenn die das einfach so genannt hätten.
Die Datei, die man runterlädt, heißt Report, YouTube, blablabla, DocX.
Zumindest unter der Haube ist es ein Zip.
Und wenn man das Zip entpackt, bekommt man zwei Dateien.
Nämlich noch mal zwei weitere Fake-Word-Dokumente.
Punkt DocX, Punkt Temp, SCA und eine Exe.
Nämlich einmal ein Word-Dokument.tmp und einmal ein Word-Dokument.scr.
.scr ist ein Bildschirmschoner für Windows, ist im Prinzip eine Exe, also ausführbare Datei.
An der Stelle noch mal angemerkt, es gibt gerade einen weiteren Scam.
Fällt mir gerade ein, das muss ich jetzt mal erzählen.
Es gibt einen weiteren Scam, es gibt Leute, die sich versuchen, auf YouTube als mich auszugeben.
Habe ich letztens auf Twitter schon mal vorgewarnt.
Das hat YouTube aber mittlerweile wirklich ganz gut im Griff, ich habe lange nichts mehr gesehen.
Es sollten euch irgendwelche Leute unter meinen Videos antworten, dass ihr in irgendwelchen Gewinnspielen gewonnen habt.
Und sie deswegen auf Telegram kontaktieren wollt, äh sollt.
Congratulations, you have been selected among our Swordlist Winners. Inbox me. Available on Telegram.
Was?
Lasst es einfach bleiben, das bin ich ich.
YouTuber kennt das mittlerweile ganz gut.
Oftmals kommt trotzdem noch sowas durch, ich lösch das auch immer, wenn ich sehe.
Aber das bin ich ich. Ich mach eh so gut wie nie irgendwelche Gewinnspiele.
Wobei man sagen muss, habe ich beim Sollmecke gehört, es sind gar nicht Gewinnspiele, sondern es sind Auslopungen, muss man dazu sagen.
Muss man schon korrekt sein.
Aber antwortet da nicht drauf, das ist fake, das bin ich nicht und ich mach keine Gewinnspiele über Telegram.
Also zurück zu diesen zwei Dateien hier.
Nachdem ich mir das Ganze angeguckt habe, habe ich gedacht, was Chet, Chet ich hab 10 Bitcoins gewonnen, wirklich?
Das ist jetzt aber überraschend.
Ganz schön groß, ganz schön großer Bildschirmschoner und ich hab mal analysiert, was ist denn da drinnen.
Und hier hab ich festgestellt, ach guck mal da, das ist ein.NET Programm, also ein C Sharp Programm.
Ja gut,.NET Programm. Das kommt mir sehr gelegen, weil ich hab schon relativ viele.NET Projekte gemacht.
Ich kenn mich damit eigentlich ganz gut aus und dachte mir, ich guck mir das jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter.
Oh jetzt kommt der Decompiler-Part.
Ist das geil. Er geht jetzt halt wirklich in den Scheiß rein.
Wenn schon, wenn schon, denn schon. Und man kann auch deutlich abgedrehteres Zeug machen.
Ich hab auch überlegt, wie wärs denn, wir überlegen uns eh schon eine Weile, da mal ein Video wieder zusammen zu machen.
Wie wärs denn, wenn ich das Ganze auch mal an Algorithmen verstehe, also den Florian schicke.
Hab mich gestern noch kontaktiert, er hat sich mittlerweile auch schon gemeldet und kleiner Teaser.
Es wird zu diesem Video jetzt noch einen zweiten Teil geben, wahrscheinlich bei ihm auf dem Channel.
Gleich nächste Reaction. Wir gucken uns dann nächste Woche zusammen an, wird wahrscheinlich erst nächste Woche, was?
Wir gucken uns dann nächste Woche zusammen an, was wir noch alles rausbekommen.
Nicht nur über diese Datei, sondern über die andere und vielleicht auch sogar, wer weiß, wer da so dahinter steckt.
Aber heute halbe Expose.
Erinnert mich gleich wieder an diesen, an hier, oh Mann, jetzt fällt mir der Name nicht ein.
Der diese indischen Scam-Telefon-Sendung exposed.
Ach, äh, Dings hier auf Twitch, ähm, Kidburga, oder?
Meint er wahrscheinlich.
Kidburga Beste.
Ohne Scheiß, ähm, ich guck, ich guck nicht so oft, ich guck nicht so oft.
Aber Kidburga ist wirklich ein Streamer, wo ich echt sagen muss, dem gönne ich jeden einzelnen Sub und jeden einzelnen Zuschauer komplett.
Das ist auch vom Content was, wo ich nicht sagen würde, wie kann man mit so einem Content jetzt so viele Viewer generieren, versteh ich nicht, juck mich nicht.
Ich versteh's, es ist mega lustig, es ist teilweise mega spannend, es ist, es ist richtig, richtig geil, wie er die verarscht und das kann auch wirklich nicht jeder.
Der ist so gut, was diese, der ist so spontan und, ähm, dem fällt, dem fällt so gut immer wieder irgendwas, irgendwas so aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt ein, also das ist wirklich richtig, richtig gut.
Also dem gönne ich wirklich jeden, jeden Viewer.
...Dokument an, was hier eigentlich ins Screen...
So ein Vibe hab ich gerade.
Es ist ein.NET Programm,.NET hat den, hat die nette Eigenschaft, dass man ein.NET Programm...
Jim Browning, Jim Browning, Chet.
Ach ja, mein Jim Browning, ich, äh, ich mein Kid Boga.
Relativ einfach dekompilieren kann, beziehungsweise, ähm, zurückumwandeln kann.
Ich finde, was ich da immer am besten finde, sind die Inder, wenn die, es gibt so einen Standardsatz bei Kid Boga, mit den Indern, wo er telefoniert.
Die sagen, die sagen immer, wenn sie nicht weiter wissen, sagen die immer, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, so hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, sagen die alle im gleichen Ton.
...in halbwegs lesbaren Source Code.
Es gibt da zum Beispiel sowas wie IELTS bei, und das gucken wir uns jetzt mal zusammen an, was denn da drinne eigentlich passiert.
So, hier sind wir, wir sind übrigens nicht in IELTS bei, sondern wir sind in Rider, das ist eine.NET Entwicklungsumgebung, die hat aber auch einen dekompiler.
So, jetzt komm ich langsam an meine Grenzen von dem, was ich überhaupt verstehen kann.
So, jetzt ist vorbei.
Dabei, und es sieht wahnsinnig wirr aus, und warum sieht das Ganze so wirr aus, das kann ich euch auch zeigen.
Sie verwenden nämlich einen.NET Obfuscator, das erkenne ich hieran, die verwenden Smart Assembly.
Was ein.NET Obfuscator macht, ist relativ easy zu erklären.
Easy, ich hätte vielleicht nicht easy sagen sollen, aber gut.
Und zwar versucht er, das Programm möglichst zu verschleiern, was da drin passiert.
Das heißt, beim Kompilieren wird das nicht einfach eins zu eins so übersetzt, wie es normalerweise wird,
sondern es wird, bevor es wirklich kompiliert wird in der ausführbaren Datei, das Ganze noch möglichst unkenntlich gemacht,
dass man es nicht mehr so einfach zurück umwandeln kann in lesbaren.NET Code.
Und dann kommt dann solche abartigen Konstrukte raus, wie hier.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist ein Obfuscated.NET Programm immer noch ein.NET Programm, was man an einigen Stellen erkennt.
Man sieht hier zum Beispiel, okay, es scheint eine WinROS Forms Anwendung zu sein in der Textbox und solche Sachen, das erkennt man.
Aber viel interessanter ist, was passiert denn hier eigentlich noch drin?
Also ich erkenne daran gar nichts, aber da bin ich halt raus aus Anwendungsentwicklung.
Das ist halt...
Das hier oben können wir uns alles schenken.
Das blicke ich da nicht.
Naja, wirklich blicken habe ich es beim ersten Mal angucken auch nicht.
Ich musste mir da schon ein paar Minuten angucken und ein bisschen gucken, welche Variable steht was drin.
Aber wenn man es verstanden hat, ist es tatsächlich relativ einfach, also an der Stelle noch relativ einfach zu verstehen, weil einfach nur was runtergeladen wird.
... uns auch schenken, aber das ist interessant. Guckt mal da.
Das ist eine URL.
Ich mache das hier neben mal ein bisschen zu. Das ist eine URL zu. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Einem Wordpress-Blog.
Leute, macht die Adresse nicht auf.
Vor allem, warum ist es eigentlich immer Wordpress?
Und das geht wohl offensichtlich nicht zu Images, sondern zu irgendeinem Binary.
Also es gibt eine Download-Adresse.
Was passiert mit der Download-Adresse?
Oder mit der URL?
Hier unten wird das runtergeladen.
Die laden das runter und lesen es dann in den Arbeitsspeicher ein.
Und dann, und jetzt kommt nochmal ein bisschen was abgedrückt.
Jetzt kommt High IQ Time.
Und dann, wenn das Programm runtergeladen wurde, ich zeige euch das mal, ich habe das Programm nämlich auch runtergeladen.
Oder beziehungsweise, ja, eigentlich ist es erst mal random Daten, die runtergeladen werden.
Jetzt kommt Text, jetzt kommt der Hex-Editor gleich.
Die runtergeladene Datei. Gehen wir mal hier rein.
Und schauen uns das mal an. Ihr seht, hier habe ich das Ganze runtergeladen.
Ist bloß noch 629 Kilobyte groß, das Ganze.
Wenn wir uns da jetzt mal angucken.
Um genau zu sein, müsste man wahrscheinlich Kiwi-Byte oder sowas sagen.
Was es ist. Dann sehen wir, es ist einfach nur Data.
Doch, doch, es gibt einen De-Opfer-Scader. Das machen wir dann im zweiten Teil.
Und man kann da auch nicht wirklich was drin erkennen.
Also ich habe das versucht zu öffnen.
Wir können beispielsweise mal einen Hex-Dump darauf machen.
Wir sehen, das ist ziemlich...
Digga!
Er ist für mich gerade schwarzer Magier an der Tastatur.
Ich bin so raus, Max, gerade.
Ich bin so raus, für mich so interessant.
Aber jetzt denke ich nur noch...
Bruder, er ist halt einfach...
Da gibt es ja auch nichts drin zu erkennen.
Ich will doch in dem Video zeigen, dass man darin nichts erkennt.
Das ist doch gerade der Witz.
Richtiger Hacker-Man am Start.
Nichts, nichts.
Das ist einfach Hacker-Man. Das könnte auch ein Matrix-Code sein, der abläuft.
Weißt du?
Genau. Wenn du das in grün machst und das durchlaufen lässt,
würde ich denken, du bist in der Matrix.
Wir könnten es nach LOL-Cat-Pipen.
Dann ist es in Regenbogenfarben.
Gib mir den... Wo ist fucking Keanu Reeves gerade?
...ragendes Zeug.
Da ist so richtiger Nerdshit gerade.
Holy moly.
Irgendeine Art und Weise verschlüsselt.
Wobei man sich jetzt fragen kann.
Da kann der Florian sicherlich mehr dazu sagen nächste Woche.
Ist sie fraglich, ob es wirklich eine Verschlüsselung ist?
Oder ob das einfach nur ein bisschen
randomized, ein bisschen
rumencoded ist und eigentlich relativ
einfach zu entschlüsseln.
Aber wir müssen uns gar keine großen Gedanken
darüber machen, wie könnte man das jetzt
vielleicht knacken oder wie könnte man das entschlüsseln,
was sie da runterladen, weil
sie liefern die Entschlüsselung gleich mit.
Guckt mal hier, was hier noch in dem
Programm passiert. Das heißt hier unten
laden sie das Ganze runter
und hier
entschlüsseln sie. Das ist
Stay.
Ich bin mir noch gar nicht mal sicher, ob man das überhaupt so ausspricht,
aber ich glaube schon.
Das hier, auch wenn es absichtlich
so gemacht ist, dass es keine Sau lesen kann.
Ich meine, das ist der schlechteste.NET
Code, den ich je gelesen habe. Go to
und Labels und sonstige Geschichten.
Es ist absichtlich so gemacht, dass es keine
Sau versteht, aber man erkennt
was passiert und zwar wird das
runtergeladen, dann kommt diese Datei
wird hier
eingelesen. Go to ist
Toss, ja. Wird hier eingelesen und dann
wird das Label und Go to ist richtig
mit diesem ganzen Kram hier. Das ist
eine XOR-Verschlüsselung oder
XOR mit sonst was.
Wir müssen uns da aber gar keinen großen Gedanken
drüber machen, weil es ist ja gültiges
C Sharp.
Es ist ja gültiges C Sharp.NET.
Wir können einfach ein eigenes Programm
machen, das hier rein kopieren
und die runtergeladene Datei damit
entschlüsseln. Sixhead.
Sixhead-Time
für ihn jetzt.
Digga, ich fühle mich gerade
so wie
Jean-Luc das erste Mal
in der siebten IT-Unterricht und
der Lehrer steht vorne und sagt
Elect Critical Information
an der Stelle.
So, dann lass uns mal
über HTML sprechen.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Ich bin vollkommen, ich bin gerade vollkommen
das ist natürlich dann, da bin ich
einfach aus. Hände hoch HTML-Programmierer.
Dafür bin ich nicht schlau genommen. Also ich habe
mal das Ganze genommen und habe es hier
eingehauen. Ihr seht, hat sich nichts
großartig geändert. Das ist exakt
diesen Kram, den ich hier aus diesem
dekompilierten C Sharp raus
bekommen habe. Eins zu eins.
Rein kopiert in ein eigenes Projekt.
Ich habe eine Zeile geändert,
dass der Compiler das Ganze frisst
und ich lade die Datei von
meiner Platte und
lasse ich durch diese Decoding
Funktion durchlaufen. Eins zu eins
kopiert aus diesem vermeintlichen
Malware-Programm und am Ende
stelle ich aus diesem ganzen
Suss.bin.
Suss.bin nennt.
Also sprich, wir
entschlüsseln quasi damit das, was
aus dieser WordPress-Seite runtergeladen
wird. Das, was die quasi auch versuchen
bei euch dann auf dem Rechner, wenn ihr euch
diesen Screensaver eingefangen habt.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was hier... Kannst du mir
ein Antivirus empfehlen? Ja, Windows Defender, fertig
aus.
Wir machen mal File, Suss.bin
und wir sehen, es ist ein weiteres
.NET-Programm. Also die Malware-
Entwickler oder die Angreifer stehen wirklich
auf.NET. Oder aber
vielleicht kriegen sie auch... Das ist das
dritte.NET-Programm in einem
.NET-Programm. Korrekt. Da wurde ursprünglich
was runtergeladen, das hat auch einen Server
connectiert, das hat wieder was runtergeladen, das hat was
entpackt und das ist wieder ein.NET-Programm.
Kriegen sie auch Software-Entwicklung selbst nicht
hin und haben einfach... Es ist so wie diese
russischen
Spielzeug-Pop so nach dem Motto
und was ist drin ein.NET-Programm und
was ist da drin ein.NET-Programm.
Ich habe euch zusammen kopiert, es gibt
viel Windows-Mailware in.NET.
Tja, und was machen wir jetzt?
Ich würde sagen,
wir gucken uns auch mal den Decompiler-Output
Halbe Truschka, oder wie das heißt.
Stimmt, diese Figuren in den
Figuren, ja, so ein bisschen.
Wir hatten die gleiche Idee. Diesmal
aber in EL-Spy. So,
und hier habe ich das Ganze jetzt in EL-Spy auf
und wir sehen... Boah! Flashbang!
In EL-Spy.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, aber wir
müssen mal gucken.
Eigentlich ist das Video mehr oder weniger fertig
ja auch schon jetzt. Es ist wieder obfoskeletet.
Es ist noch mehr obfoskeletet
wie das erste Programm. Das heißt, hier kann man
jetzt gar nichts mehr erkennen, was passiert.
Keine Ahnung. Fake-Methoden drin,
keine Strings erkennbar.
Was man allerdings erkennt, und das finde ich auch schon mal
ganz interessant, und das werde ich mir nächste
Woche mit dem Florian zusammen auch ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Was man schon mal erkennt,
ist, es ist ein weiteres.NET-Programm,
was eben wieder Windows Forms verwendet.
Also es ist ein weiteres GUI-Programm, gerade mit
grafischer Oberfläche. Alter, das ist das
vierte.NET-Programm. Die holen dann wahrscheinlich
wieder ein.NET-Programm. Nein, nein, nein!
Das ist das gleiche.
Das ist nur der Decompiler-Output.
Komm runter, oder was? Also es ist
wahrscheinlich ein Verschlüsselungstrojaner,
der den dann anzeigen möchte. Hier,
wir haben ihre Daten. Bitte Bitcoin überweisen.
Es könnte aber auch genauso gut
Keylogger sein.
Es könnte auch Sessions abgreifen
von Browsern. Das ist ja auch das,
wo viele YouTuber angegriffen
werden, oder generell Streamer angegriffen werden,
in dem einfach entweder komplette Rechner
ferngesteuert wird, oder... Das ist das, was
Julien Bam passiert ist, übrigens. Session-Daten
aus ihren Browsern, aus ihren Cookies geklaut
wird, und jemand anderen schickt,
ist alles denkbar.
Und das ist
was, an der Stelle muss ich sagen, das ist mir...
Warum schaust du das gerade, also der SIN? Willst du ein paar Idioten
hacken, Kappa? Ne, ich will niemanden
hacken, ich will... Ja, ja!
Das ist keine Anleitung! Oh, sagt das YouTube bitte
nicht zu laut, sonst wird das
noch als Hacking-Content erkannt.
Warum so viele YouTube-Content? Das darf man auf YouTube
nicht sagen!
Ich meine, es ist kein Hacking-Content!
Das ist keine Anleitung und nichts!
Aber trotzdem,
bei YouTube ja nie. Und sowas zu verstehen, dient ja auch
zum Schutz, ne?
Das ist fast dran, ja. Es gibt Programme,
mit denen kann man solche verschleierten
.NET-Programme
wieder entschleiern,
also rückgängig machen, dass es wieder besser
lesbar ist, aber das ist mir an der Stelle
jetzt auf jeden Fall ein bisschen zu heikel, weil
dazu muss man die Software meistens ausführen.
Das mache ich nächste Woche mit dem Florian zusammen,
das heißt, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, lasst mir
ein Abo da. Nächstes Mal mit
Kali Linux, ja, für den richtigen Hacker
Flair, ja. Gucken, ich habe ihn unten verlinkt.
Und ich
fasse es jetzt am Ende nochmal zusammen,
das heißt, ich habe eine Mail gekriegt,
darin war ein Download, ZIP
mit einem Fake Screen Safer,
dieser Fake Screen Safer,
wenn man den ausführt,
wird eigentlich unter der Haube
ein Programm ausgeführt, was ein weiteres
Programm von einem Wordpress
in... Ich fragte jemanden, kannst du
programmieren? Nee, kann ich nicht. Ich habe mich damals
bei der Fachinformatik
für die Systemintegration entschieden und nicht für die Anwendung.
Ah, ist tatsächlich fisi. Programmieren
war mir immer schon zu...
Deswegen checkt er
auch ungefähr so, um was es geht. Das hat mich
am Anfang schon ein bisschen gewundert und ich dachte, okay,
hat er schon einen ganz guten Durchblick.
Aber gut, wenn er Fisi gelernt hat, hat er zumindest so Basics da.
So obscure, das habe ich nie gecheckt.
Die Basics. Nachlädt und
das dann ausführt. So.
Wunderbar. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt
unseren kompletten Rechner, theoretisch hätte ich das ausgeführt,
Malware verseucht
und im Arsch.
Jetzt mache ich mir nochmal einen Spaß und
ganz am Ende laden wir mal
eine dieser Dateien auf Virus total hoch
und gucken,
was so passiert. So, nehmen wir das mal.
Der Part ist jetzt eigentlich
langweilig.
Das geht schon gut los.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Eigentlich haben wir da gar nichts wirklich
Schlimmes, muss man mal dazu sagen. Das habe ich
im Video vielleicht nicht so gut erklärt.
Das sind alles, wobei das erkläre ich im Video,
das sind alles keine
wirklichen Viren, die direkt
erkannt worden, weil eine Signatur drin ist.
Das ist alles Analyse.
Also es ist alles quasi
nicht Verhaltensanalyse, sondern
quasi so Heuristik.
So nach dem Motto, ah, das verwendet
die und die Library, das könnte ein Virus sein.
Ah, das ist compressed,
obfoscated, das könnte
ein Virus sein. Das ist kein direkter
Signal, also kein direkter Signatur,
kein wirklicher Virus. Und das sieht man
auch hier dran oftmals, weil irgendwas von
Gen und Heurer
und sowas dran steht.
Die sind sich sicher
malicious, 100%.
Ich habe es gestern übrigens schon hochgeladen.
Deswegen muss er das Ganze jetzt hier mal
scannen. Also man sieht, der erkennt
hier einige
Verdächtigen. Sind diese Signaturen
eigentlich Hashes? Ich kann dir nicht so genau
sagen, wie Viren-Scanner das genau
machen.
Aber sie können keine
Hashes in dem Sinn sein, weil du musst
ja gucken, ob
der Part wirklich so vorkommt.
Sonst müsstest du ja den
Input hashen und mit
Hashes, also ne, das Signatur
muss schon das
Beidweise sein, was du suchst.
Muster, allerdings muss man auch
sagen, das hier alles
ist kein sicherer Hinweis darauf, dass es
ein Virus ist. Man sieht, dass
das Video mit dem Florian kommt mir noch nicht aufnehmen.
Machen wir noch, Chet.
Also ein verschleiertes.NET-Programm ist.
Es ist suspicious, es sind
wirklich keine Matches
in dem Sinn, wo man sagt, ey,
das
ist sicher ein Virus, sondern das Meiste
sind irgendwelche
Verhaltenserkennungs...
Kannst du den Screenshot mit Wasser
im Streamer zeigen, sodass wir es sehen?
Verhaltenserkennungs...
Sie sind sich hier
relativ sicher, dass es
G32MSIL Kryptik
ist.
Was auch immer da dahinter steckt. Ich muss mal kurz suchen.
Es ist Obfuscated, das an sich ist
noch nicht so schlimm, aber zumindest denken an
der Stelle schon einige Antiviren-Hersteller.
Irgendwas stimmt mit
dieser Datei nicht. Und was genau gucken
wir uns da nächste Woche zusammen an?
Das heißt, wir machen an der Stelle Schluss, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen. Also ich bin
auch da jetzt. Ja, sehr krasses Video von
Max. Sehr... also
ich kriege das natürlich nicht auf die Reihe.
Bis zur Hälfte bin ich mitgekommen.
Der Link ist im YouTube-Chat gerade.
Ich kriege das natürlich nicht auf die Reihe.
Wenn da solche Sachen passieren, denke ich mir
so, alter Digga, da bin ich ja vollkommen raus.
Das ist
bisschen, bisschen crazy.
Ja, deswegen mache ich ja auch Videos zu,
dass man das sich in Ruhe angucken kann,
ohne selbst machen zu müssen. Hier ist das
Bild.
Mit...
mit...
Ihr seht's ja, ihr seht's ja mit
Wasserzeichen und sowas.
So sah das im Original aus.
Und Leute hier, ich mach's mal unkenntlich,
ja, sonst geben's wieder irgendwelche Leute
ein. Das...
Äh, so sah das, guck,
hier so richtig mit Wasserzeichen gedröhnt im Hintergrund.
Sieht man schlecht,
ja, aber jetzt sieht man's wenigstens.
Letztens auf einem Nass
zehntausendundvier. Ganz wichtig,
die vier.
Musste erst mal schaffen.
Ja, so sah das, so sah das
im Original aus.
Ja.
Okay.
Ups.
So, bissl, bissl gedudel
anmachen wieder.
Äh, ich hatte mich letztens wegen Arbeiten
als Informatiker bei der Bundeswehr interessiert.
Du hattest dich so angehört, als wäre das nicht
so ne gute Idee. Kannst du jemand der Arbeit...
Äh, nee, nee, ähm, gar nicht.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das bei der Bundeswehr ist.
Ich persönlich hätte bloß keinen Bock für die Bundeswehr zu arbeiten.
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig schlecht sein.
Von, von, von, von der
Stelle. Keine Ahnung.
Ich persönlich hätte bloß
keinen Bock drauf, bei der Bundeswehr zu arbeiten.
Ja. So, jetzt geht's weiter
mit krassem Hacker-Content, Leute. Im Titel
steht's schon. Arch, by the way,
Linux Desktop weiter customisen.
Ich
zeige euch mal, wo
wir stehen geblieben sind.
Da gehe ich auch von aus.
Also, okay.
Ich kenne niemand, der bei der Bundeswehr
in der IT gearbeitet hat.
Ich kenne aber jemand, der bei der Army,
bei den...
frag mich nicht genau wo, also bei der US Army
gearbeitet hat.
In der IT.
Der war
Fallschirmspringer
und Admin in einem.
Auch, auch, auch, auch eine geile
Kombination.
Und, ähm,
da drüber ohne Scheiß, da, da drüber
müsste ich mit, müsste ich mit ihm eigentlich mal ein Video
aufnehmen.
Darüber müsste ich mit ihm eigentlich mal ein Video lernen.
Also, der, der war Fallschirmspringer
und Admin.
Er hatte, der musste
halt dort Militärausbildung machen
und da gehörte halt Fallschirmspringen und so dabei.
Und ich glaube, er war bei irgendein, bei irgendein
Fallschirmspringer, wie heißt das,
ähm, Batallion
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und die haben dort
richtig krasse Sachen gemacht.
Also, wo ich mir auch denke,
was ist das für ein Video?
wer macht das AOBS Chat?
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe,
wo ich mir immer denke, wer macht das denn freiwillig?
Also, da muss man ihm eins
entlassen, der ist wirklich extrem hart
im Nehmen. Ähm, wenn der nicht
halt pot ist, kommt er auf die Arbeit und das
ist auch der einzige, dem ich zutrauen
würde, wenn das Gebäude brennt und
einem selbst fällt was aufs Bein
und man kann nicht mehr laufen, der zieht dich,
der zieht dich raus, ja.
Also, auf den kannst du dich verlassen. Wenn der sagt,
der macht was, dann macht das und
er rettet dich im Zweifelsfall auch aus dem brennenden Gebäude.
Also, der ist hart drauf, der ist so
hart drauf, der ist mal auf
einem nach Hause
Weg, ist der
über eine lose Platte
im Gehweg gefallen
und hat sich das Knie auf
ge...
Knie ist aufgeplatzt, sodass
gepludet hat und der
hat gemeint, als er dann zu Hause
war, paar Stunden später wäre
das Knie irgendwie, wäre irgendwie sein Knie dreimal
so dick gewesen
und
aber anderen Tag war er wieder arbeiten
wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, Mensch
willst du nicht mal zum Doktor gehen?
Also, er ist zwar wirklich hart im Leben
zumindest, die haben da mehrere, die haben da richtig
heftige Sachen gemacht, der musste
Fallschirm springen und der musste
so einen
Trenengaskammer-Test machen
da haben sie die Leute irgendwie eine halbe Stunde
in so eine Kammer mit Trenengas gesteckt
irgendwie zehn Leute
und dann gab es das
Kommando drin, dass sie jetzt die Gasmaske
ausziehen müssen
und da mussten sie eine halbe Stunde in dieser
Trenengaskammer ohne Gasmaske
quasi aushalten
und durften vorher nicht raus
und die Leute
müssen da wohl wirklich gehustet, gekotzt
und alles haben drinne
also, die sind wirklich
heftig drauf, die Jungs, also wenn du das alles hinter dir hast
dann schockt dich so ein bisschen IT-Arbeitsalltag
auch gar nicht mehr
dann schockt dich nichts mehr
tja
zumindest
das würde ich nicht bei der Bundeswehr
erwarten, weil bei der Bundeswehr, wenn du in die
IT gehst, dann geht es ja weniger darum, dass du quasi
Soldat mit IT bist, sondern
du machst wahrscheinlich deine
Basic-Ausbildung und dann bist du halt
zwar offiziell Soldat, aber
hauptsächlich Admin, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
aber trotzdem, ich persönlich
hätte keinen Bock auf die Bundeswehr
das Militärischste, was ich in meinem Leben gemacht habe
war die Fahrtfinder, als ich jung war
also der könnte unter
Trenengas Festplatten tauschen
kein Ding, easy
ich suche in
letzter Zeit das Video, wo du den kleinen
Semper-Video-Joke machst, weißt du
zufällig noch welches, das war
das Semper-Video-Joke
ich hab schon öfters mal, also Just For Fun
gesagt, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
ne, oder wie ging das
in diesem Video nur kurz nehmen wollen
jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, wie gehts nochmal, genau
in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
gezeigt
auf den Router
ja
ansonsten weiß ich nicht, in welchem Video
ich den Witz gemacht hab
so, also
kommen wir mal, jetzt nach einer Stunde
zum eigentlichen Teil
des Streams
wo wir weiter unsere
Linux VM einrichten
und in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
gezeigt, genau, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
gezeigt
und in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
gezeigt, genau, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz
gezeigt
also ich bin kein großartiger
Portena-Fan, hab ich schon öfters
gesagt
also, ich bin selbst für mich
den Mehrwert nicht drinne
aber kann jeder machen wie er will
weiß ich gar nicht, wer mir da zuviel
Videos zu machen kann
kannst du dann, wenn du Arbeitgeber gewechselt hast
wieder Geschichten aus dem Rechenzentrum machen, fand ich
lustig, ich hab noch genug Geschichten aus dem
Rechenzentrum, wo ich beim Provider, beim
Provider gearbeitet habe
beim neuen
werd ich auch nicht so oft im Rechenzentrum sein
geh ich davon aus, also
bin ich mir relativ sicher
ich genau weiß ich, weiß ich's nicht
aber bin ich mir relativ sicher, weil
die ganzen großen Unternehmen haben meistens
zu diesem Betrieb vom Rechenzentrum
entweder outgesourced, also
das reine Festplattenwechseln
einbauen, ausbauen, Kabel legen und so
oder haben irgendeinen Team, was sie
explizit drum kümmert
auf geht's, also, wo sind wir stehengeblieben
White Pepo Happy Time
ok, folgendermaßen
wir sind gestern stehengeblieben bei unserem
Launcher, den hab ich wieder runtergeschmissen
weil wir noch was anderes machen
ich kann mir den aufmachen
also hier sind wir gestern stehengeblieben
wir haben einen ordentlich konfigurierten Desktop
mit einem super Desktop Background
ganz wichtig, den brauchen wir
warum auch immer hier
der Kreisel kreiselt
Super Pepo White Pepo Happy Background
so wir haben
ein super nicees Terminal gefunden
auf GitHub, nennt sich
Wes
und ich hab
noch ein bisschen an der Konfigurung gespielt
das ist E3, genau, das hab ich gar nicht vergessen zu erwähnen
das ist E3, als
Window Manager, man kann ja nicht wirklich
Desktop sagen, Desktop in dem Sinn haben wir nicht
keine Icons oder sonst was
und ansonsten
also heute müssen wir uns darum
kümmern, dass wir hier ordentlichen Status bar kriegen
auch mit Transparenz, was nicht so aussieht wie von 1995
und das alles so ein bisschen
schicker machen, ja
zumindest, was machen
die Emojis, die funktionieren alle
guck, alle Emojis
alle, alle
ich kann nicht Copy Pasten so
Emojis
guck, kann ich Emojis
Emojis im Terminal
das
wichtigste vom wichtigen
das geht natürlich
man könnte sogar mal
Emoji Spam machen
wie gesagt, das ist E3
allerdings
noch gar nicht so sehr
Customized, bisher nur das Terminal
ich muss euch eine Sache
zeigen, weil
wie gesagt ich hab die ersten
15 Emoji Spams
Wie gesagt, ich habe die ersten 15 Minuten das Terminal ein bisschen schlecht geredet,
weil es schlechte Default-Settings hat, aber insgesamt ist es mega mega nice.
Ich kann das wirklich jedem nur empfehlen, sich das mal anzugucken und zwar, ich habe
heute noch ein paar Sachen rausbekommen, was man mit dem Terminal machen kann und die
Config ist tatsächlich, auch wenn es Lua ist, die Config ist wirklich super nice, ihr
könnt es in der Bar unten auch, und zwar, was ich rausgefunden habe, was man machen
kann ist, zum Beispiel kann man einer Taste mehrere Aktionen zuweisen, zum Beispiel das
hier, guckt mal, wenn ich jetzt was markiere und gleich kommt Mindblown, ich sag's euch,
auf die Idee bin ich selbst nicht gekommen, ich hab das gelesen in der Beispiel Config,
ich muss sagen, das ist die beste Idee, was Terminal-Bedienung angeht seit langer Zeit,
die ich gesehen habe, und zwar, als erstes, wo ich festgestellt habe, man kann mehrere
Befehle ausführen, das ist, wenn ich jetzt was markiere und ich kopiere es in meine Zwischenablage,
dann deselectet er wieder, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo es deselectet wird, weiß ich,
jetzt ist es in der Zwischenablage und ich kann es einfügen, das ist schon mal cool,
das geht an der Stelle, dass man ihm sagt, man möchte mehrere Aktionen auf eine Maustaste
beinden, also guck, ich hab auf der rechten Maustaste mehrere Aktionen, das Markierte
ins Clipboard kopieren und dann die Selection entfernen, das ist schon mal cool, aber jetzt
kommt Massive Sixhead Hi-IQ, Copy, ich hoffe, ich finde das noch, ich hab's aber irgendwo,
ich hab's aber irgendwo, ja, was für ein Theme hast du, du meinst, im Terminal, ein
selbstgebasteltes Theme, was auf Tomorrow Night basiert, der Grund, warum es selbstgebastelt
ist, ist schnell erklärt, erstens hat das Terminal einen Bug in der Version, die ich
hier habe, in der letzten stable Version, wenn man ein Farbschema angibt, dann hat es
Lacks, aber in den Standard Themes sind auch ein paar Sachen nicht gesetzt, wie zum Beispiel
die Selection und manche haben den Cursor nicht richtig gesetzt und sowas, deswegen
hab ich das hier selbst gemacht, das ist relativ easy, ich hab mir so einen Theme kopiert
und hab dann die Sachen hinzugefügt, die ich noch gebraucht hab, dann ist gut, so, aber
jetzt mindblown Leute, die beste Idee für Konsolenbedienung, die ich seit langer Zeit
gesehen hab, das hier, ihr kennt doch das Problem, dass überall auf der Welt und in
Windows und unter Linux, egal wo, außer Mac, außer Mac, da ist es eine andere Taste, Copy
und Paste ist überall Ctrl C, Ctrl V, außer in einem Terminal, warum nicht in einem Terminal,
ich kanns euch zeigen, wenn ihr z.B. im Terminal ein Programm ausführt, was hängt und ihr
das beenden müsst, dann müsst ihr Ctrl C drücken, weil Ctrl C eben cancel und abbrechen
ist im Terminal, man sieht ja auch noch das Capesymbol, also man kann im Terminal nicht
Ctrl C verwenden zum Kopieren, weil Ctrl C im Terminal schon belegt ist und zwar mit
einer wirklich essentiell wichtigen Funktion, Befehle abbrechen, das braucht man, das kann
man auch nicht ohne auskommen, das braucht man, so und was meistens passiert ist, dass
die Leute sich Ctrl Shift C mappen, also ich mach Ctrl Shift C und dann kann ichs einfügen,
ja, genau, da gibt es die Möglichkeit das mit Umschalt zu machen, mit der mittleren
Maustaste, hier mittlere Maustaste oder wie ich jetzt habe rechte, rechte Maustaste, ja
immer Befehle abbrechen, umbinden würde ich auf gar keinen Fall machen, das ist so ein
elementarer grundsätzlicher Befehl, den du auch remote auf irgendwelchen Servern brauchst,
du willst schon dran gewöhnt sein, dass Ctrl C im Terminal auch wirklich abbricht, das
ist keine gute Idee das umzulegen, ja oder machst rechtsklick und dann einfügen und
sowas, aber Sixhead Idee, guckt euch das mal an, das ist ne mega geile Idee und zwar
quasi so ne Art Makrobinden auf Ctrl C und zwar checken, if es gibt eine Selection in
dem Fenster, dann fungiert Ctrl C als Copy, wenn es keine Selection gibt, dann fungiert
es als Ctrl C, nämlich Kommando abbrechen, das heißt, wenn ich hier was kopieren will,
hab hier das markiert, dann kann ich Ctrl C drücken und es bricht nicht ab, sondern
es macht es ins Clipboard und wenn ich nichts markiert habe, dann bricht es das Kommando
ab und ich mein ganz ehrlich, du kopierst ja nicht random irgendwas, einfach mal so und
lässt es dann ausführen, wenn du abbrechen willst, hast du eigentlich nix, hast du eigentlich
nix, nix selected, ja, das finde ich ist ne mega Idee und das werde ich mal ausprobieren,
das haue ich mir bei mir in die Config rein, mal gucken, mal gucken ob es dort nicht irgendwelche
Haken daran gibt, also könnte ja sein, dass es jetzt gar nicht so cool ist, wie ich mir
das vielleicht vorstelle, so, also, Bind, Ctrl C, da und da, da und da, ok, passt,
speichern, alles klar, so und wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt das hier anklicke und ich drücke
jetzt Ctrl C, habt ihr es gesehen, jetzt hat er kopiert und jetzt kann ich wieder einfügen,
ich kann jetzt übrigens auch Ctrl V mappen, dann kann ich im Terminal wirklich Ctrl C
Ctrl V machen, allerdings nur, allerdings nur wenn ich was selected habe und man sieht
auch, ob das mit der Selection klappt, weil die Selection geht ja danach weg und was noch
viel cooler ist, beangenehm, ich hab aus Versehen was selected und führe jetzt was aus, da muss
ich einfach einmal mehr Ctrl C drücken, dass es abbricht, das ist auch kein, das ist auch
kein Beinbruch, kein Beinbruch, weil ganz im Ernst, ich weiß nicht wie ihr das macht,
aber wenn ich was abbrechen will, ich halte eigentlich bestimmt 2-3 Sekunden Ctrl C oftmals
gedrückt, dass das Ding auch wirklich abbricht, also das ist wirklich eine mega nice Idee
und ich glaube das werde ich so lassen, ja, dann habe ich noch was weiteres rausgefunden,
was ich euch auch noch kurz zeigen will, aber ich mappe mir erstmal noch schnell, hier Paste,
ich mappe mir erstmal schnell noch, ähm, wie oft benutzt du Escape im Terminal, selten,
so, ähm, Moment, Spawn, ich will nicht Spawn, ich will das da haben, ich weiß man kann den
Vim besser navigieren, aber ich bin Vim Noob was das angeht, Ctrl, ich will nicht C, ich
will Ctrl V haben und jetzt kann ich theoretisch mit Ctrl V auch einfügen, ich kann Ctrl C
und Ctrl V in meinem Terminal verwenden und trotzdem abbrechen, ja in Vim braucht man
das aber normalerweise im Terminal, so brauchst du es nicht, so und eine andere Sache, die
ich auch noch sehr nice finde, die ich rausgefunden habe und zwar, ich habe Caps Lock umgelegt
und zwar ist es ja so, früher habe ich immer T-Max benutzt, also ich installiere das jetzt
immer schnell, dass ich euch zeigen kann, ähm, so, mit T-Max kannst du ja im Terminal solche
Sachen machen, wie, jetzt hat man noch eine zweite Leiste und so, ignoriert das mal, so
wie Terminal Splitten, Terminal links und rechts Splitten und solche Geschichten, das braucht
man nicht mehr, weil in, in West Term ist was ähnliches eingebaut, man kann in West
Term nämlich z.B. sagen Split, Split, ohne dass man T-Max braucht, es ist wichtig, dass
das Terminal trotzdem T-Max über SSH und sowas gescheit unterstützt, weil auf Remod Servern
will man es natürlich weiter verwenden, so und was man jetzt machen kann ist folgendes,
wenn man Caps Lock nicht braucht, ich meine niemand, wer benutzt Caps Lock, niemand den
ich kenne benutzt Caps Lock, man kann Caps Lock als Escape, quasi nicht als Escape, als
Leader Key heißt das, also quasi als Escape Sequence Key benutzen, ich habe hier oben
gesagt mein Leader Key ist Caps Lock, Void Symbol ist Caps Lock, fragt mich bitte nicht
warum und jetzt kann ich die ganzen T-Max Mappings, die ich früher benutzt habe, äh,
kann ich jetzt von Ctrl B, weil das braucht man ja für Key, für T-Max, umlegen auf Caps
Lock, das heißt wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt splitten will, wenn ich das vertikal
splitten will, drücke ich Caps Lock 2, oder wenn ich es horizontal splitten will, nee
umgedreht, wenn ich es horizontal splitten will drücke ich Caps Lock 5, das ist äußerst
nice oder Caps Lock Z zum ranzoomen, ne Ctrl auf Caps Lock mag ich nicht, mal gucken wie
weit ich damit klarkomme, oder wenn du neue Tabs auf hast, kann ich jetzt Caps Lock Next,
Caps Lock Next oder Caps Lock Previous Tab machen, oder Caps Lock C, also quasi wie in
T-Max gleichen Mappings, bloß auf Caps Lock, für ein neues, für Create neu, sehr praktisch,
also ich muss sagen wirklich Hut ab vor dem Dude, der das entwickelt hat, da ist Feature
mäßig so viel drin, was ich in keinem anderen Terminal bisher gesehen habe, es ist wirklich
der Wahnsinn das Ding, also es ist wirklich ganz großes, also ihr wisst ich lobe so Sachen
selten, aber es ist wirklich ganz ganz großes Kino hier, was der Typ gebaut hat, bloatet
könnte man auch sagen, aber wirklich es ist nice, ich kann jedem nur empfehlen sich das
mal anzugucken, das ist das beste, das ist das beste Terminal, was ich seit Jahren gesehen
habe, ich habe die ganze Zeit immer Gnome Terminal benutzt, aber ich wollte mir jetzt
mal was neues angucken, zumal Gnome Terminal selber ja nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wird
und das hat alles was ich haben will, das hat so Tiling Management, ordentliche Tastatur
Bedienung, es ist relativ schnell, es hat eine scriptbare Config, man kann Mausklicks
anpassen wie man das haben will, ja man könnte übrigens, was mir auch gerade einfällt, was
eine gute Sache wäre, ich habe hier aktuell eingestellt, ich habe hier aktuell eingestellt
dass ich rechtsklick mache und dann kann ich copypasten, wenn ich nichts, wenn ich nichts
in meinem, wenn ich nichts selected habe und klicke rechts, dann überschreibt er meinen
Copybuffer, weil ich habe ja hier immer eingestellt, rechtsklick, ne das wollte ich jetzt nicht
aufmachen, das wollte ich aufmachen, ich habe hier eingestellt, rechtsklick, is immer perform
action copy, also eigentlich sollte ich das hier auch machen, has selection, das kann
ich mir jetzt einfach mal kopieren, dass es nämlich nur kopiert, dass es das nur macht,
wenn es, wenn es ne selection hat, dass ich nicht aus Versehen mein Terminal cleare, warum
kann ich denn kein block select mehr machen, was ist da jetzt procken, ah ich kann kein
block select mehr machen, weil ich Ctrl V überschrieben habe, ok das ist ne doofe Idee
die Ctrl V zu überschreiben, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, nicht alles was auf den ersten
Blick nach ner guten Idee aussieht ist eine gute Idee, ja jetzt hab ich block select aus,
ok das ist tatsächlich doof, das muss ich mir nochmal überlegen ob das so ne gute Idee
gewesen ist, ups jaja, jetzt hab ich kein block select, jetzt muss ich das so machen, hier
end, ne aber warte wo muss denn das end jetzt hin, ne das end hier ist richtig, das end
muss, das end muss da hin oder, hier, ah jetzt, jetzt passts, aber zumindest jetzt sollte
ich wenn ich jetzt die rechte Maustaste drücke leer, sollte ich nix mehr überschreiben, ok
also doch keine so gute Idee mit Ctrl V, Ctrl C ist cool aber Ctrl V brauch ich im Wim
für block select öfters, also Ctrl V überschreiben ist vielleicht keine so gute Idee,
auf der anderen Seite wie oft braucht man block select im Wim hält sich eigentlich
auch in Grenzen vielleicht ist doch ne gute Idee und Implemented in Rust, West Terminal
heißt das, hast du mal Space Wim benutzt, ich hab mir das mal irgendwann angeguckt aber
so diese super bloated Wim Konfiguration, weiß ich nicht, ist nicht mein Fall, ist nicht
mein Fall, Tillix hab ich nie großartig verwendet, ich hab die ganze Zeit KnobTerminal mit T-Max
verwendet aber West Terminal hat mich überzeugt das werd ich in Zukunft verwenden und es
gibt sogar für Windows noch viel nicer, ja gut jetzt können wir weitermachen jetzt hab
ich euch die neuen Terminal Features gezeigt, ich würd sagen wir kümmern uns mal um unsere
Status, wir kümmern uns mal um unsere Statusleiste oder die sieht immer noch mega hässlich aus,
also folgendes machen wir jetzt, es gibt viele Projekte für so ne Statusleiste, ich würde
gern mal das da ausprobieren, also bisher verwende ich i3 Status Rust, also bisher sieht
das bei mir so aus, hier so, das ist die alte, das ist die alte VM, bisher sieht das so aus,
so ungefähr in die Richtung werd ichs jetzt auch machen, aber ich wollt jetzt mal das
hier ausprobieren, erstens weil der Entwickler einen sehr netten Eindruck macht, Polybar,
weil mir das zu 6-Set und zu abgedreht ist, weil Polybar kannst du ja wirklich alles drin
machen, aber man kann sich mal ein paar Sachen angucken, was ich hier ganz cool finde, was
ich gesehen hab ist, dass die sehr viele schon fertig konfigurierte integrierte Module haben,
die ich persönlich jetzt recht nützlich finde, richtig i3 und Wumbleby Status, die haben wir
nämlich zum Beispiel, wir gucken uns das mal kurz an, die haben die üblichen Sachen,
CPU Auslastung, Date Anzeige, Date Time Anzeige, das ist jetzt nichts neues, das ist Standard
0.8.15, Disk Space ist auch 0.8.15, Git finde ich tatsächlich schon mal ganz spannend,
ich hab keine Ahnung wie ihr das machen wollt, aber das hab ich hier in meiner Leiste, sprich
wenn ich hier in den Git Ordner gehe, dann hab ich das hier drin, das brauch ich nicht
nochmal, ich hab sogar mittlerweile die.NET Version hier im Terminal drinne stehen, auch
sehr nice, managest du deine.Files irgendwie, ich wollte mir Dings angucken, wie heißt das,
ich wollte mir zwei, ich wollte mir zwei Config File Manager angucken, damit ich die einfach
auch in GitHub aktuell halten kann, weil ich werd ja jeden Stream irgendwie auch nach den
Files gefragt und ich hab schon ewig das GitHub nicht mehr aktualisiert, ich werd das in
irgendeinen Config File Manager reinhauen. Man kann sich die Knöpfe anzeigen lassen,
die Buttons die gedrückt werden, kann sich das Tastaturlayout anzeigen lassen, die Load
vom System, Arbeitsspeicherauslastung, Netzwerkinfos, man kann Audio steuern, du kannst den Bildschirm
weniger Blautöne machen, CPU, Speedtest, Passwörter Manager über die Seite, Bildschirme umschalten,
Lautstärke ändern, Package Manager, Arch Updates anzeigen und solche Geschichten, eigentlich
ne richtig coole Geschichte und das wollte ich einfach mal ausprobieren, weil es sehr
viele nützliche Sachen hat und dann wollte ich, das hat mir nämlich der Chat empfohlen,
U-Launcher ausprobieren. U-Launcher. Bisher hab ich immer Rufi verwendet, aber jetzt probier
ich mal U-Launcher aus. Sollte eigentlich auch alles haben was ich haben will und hat,
ich hab gestern nämlich ein bisschen, dein Vorsteuer, ich hab mir nämlich gestern bisschen
die Extention Liste angeguckt, ich muss sagen, ich bin der Idee gar nicht so abgeneigt, wow,
was ist jetzt los, ich bin der Idee gar nicht mal so abgeneigt, das mit Plugins zu verwenden,
weil es viele coole gibt, also da müssen wir mal schauen. Packman, Packman updaten, ne
wir updaten Packman nicht, also wir updaten die Packages jetzt nicht. So also wir installieren
jetzt erstmal die Statusleiste, Status, komm wir nehmen das neueste, Pleading Edge auf geht's,
yes, so jetzt muss ich den Kram erstmal klonen und dann können wir schon mal auf die Seite
gucken wie man das überhaupt benutzt. Introduction, pip install, nein wir waren so beim Package
Manager, List Modules, bar, jo, das brauchen wir, Bumblebee Status, M Modules, Parameter
und dann ein Theme, List of Available Themes, müssen wir mal gucken, Leute ich muss euch
mal ein bisschen plenken, nee ich doch nicht, doch nicht, das hier finde ich beispielsweise
ganz hübsch, Moonlight Powerline, ich brauch auf jeden Fall noch einen anderen Font, weil
ich hab immer ganz gerne einen anderen Font in der Statusleiste wie in meinem Terminal,
einfach dass ich so, dass das irgendwie sich ein bisschen voneinander abhebt, aber auch
ein Mono Space Font, warum klont das so langsam? Ok Leute Achtung, Six Head Time, B Top, B
Top, gucken jetzt ob der überhaupt Netzwerk Traffic hat, nö der hat überhaupt kein Netzwerk
Traffic, 100 Bytes, der hängt beim klonen aus irgendwelchen Gründen, warum denn das
significa das ich ja keine Netzwerke habe, Barcode habe ich schon auntchnuggelt, Monster
ordner erstellen muss und die up to date halten muss und von hand sünden muss wenn
du mehrere rechner verwendest was ist denn jetzt das problem ist aber ist getappt down
oder was vielleicht soll ich mal neu starten ok war eine sekunde klauen geht klauen ja geht
doch ok leute wisst ihr was marie boot kann er nicht schaden ich habe so viel rum gebastelt
guck mal play singly fast boot times oh ich habe mein startskript kaputt gemacht leute
ich habe mein startskript kaputt gemacht ok mein startskript ist broken leute das müssen
wir erstmal kurz das müssen wir erstmal kurz fixen wo ist das problem ich führe vmw
so spät aus ok das ist natürlich blödsinnig so so muss das ausgeführt werden und vorher
brauchen wir noch ein sleep weil ich nicht weiß was anders geht man neu starten pepo
ist der ist nicht mehr white screen gerade jetzt funktioniert ok easy alles klar jetzt
ist wieder alles gut wir haben es gefixt firefox aufmachen session restore terminal aufmachen
hast du auch manchmal das problem das copy paste zwischen aus nicht funktioniert das liegt
daran wenn du vmw user nicht gestartet hast das ist allererste was du starten musst dann
gehts immer da ich noch nie probleme wirklich ohne scheiß es geht immer wenn es geht nur
nicht wenn vor allem der user nicht gestartet ist das geht sonst gehts immer ok darf ich
jetzt darf ich jetzt was klonen aber hängt mein stream hat gerade ein stream gelackt
leute aha voter phone was ist da los was ist da los
was meinst du mit vmw user ich meine exakt das hier dass du vmw minus user ausführst
brauchst du das copy paste funktioniert musst vmw user ausführen die tools starten reicht
nicht das ist nicht nvidia bumblebee nein das ist zu starten sag mal warum warum kann
ich grad bitte schön nix kann ich irgendwas anderes ok kann ich offizielle packages installieren
ok ich sollte vielleicht was anderes inszenieren x-glock x-glock wolltest du immer mal inszenieren
ok das funktioniert ok funktioniert funktioniert irgendwas anderes
das funktioniert ok ich glaube mein bild ist einfach ein bisschen broken das muss ich
einfach mal die bild files so jetzt haben wir es installiert jetzt haben wir hier bumblebee
status so jetzt können wir das konfigurieren wie funktioniert das wir haben es doch irgendwie
hier aufgehabt gerade introduction installation das da brauchen wir bar also ich hab keine
ich hab meine alias hier noch gar nicht konfig i3 i3 konfig bar status command gut also auf
gehts status command status command ist bumblebee status gefolgt von modules machen wir einfach
mal nur datetime weil wir machen mal wir mal mal wir halten mal wir halten mal klein so
parameter haben wir nicht und sie haben wir gesagt was wie heißt das moonlight powerline
hieß das ok status command annex warum da ist nun da ist nichts drin ok das funktioniert
schon mal wir haben das status leister wir haben immer noch diesen blöden hintergrund
wie man den hintergrund weg kriegt ganz einfach das gucke ich mir nämlich einfach aus meiner
alten konfig datei ab
bitte noch kleiner ja mich meine konfig shortcut die die workspace icons das kann man auch
gleich das kann man auch gleich mit kopieren ob er erstmal mal set no number die workspace
icons kann man rüber kopieren aber machen das auch gerade mal wenn man dabei sind workspace
icons die werde ich die werde ich die gleichen bei behalten spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen
workspace icons die funktion habe ich reloaded geht geht was
der hat missed kopiert guck mal der hat doppelt der hat hier was doppelt wo kommt das bitte
schön her so muss man die ganzen sachen mal umschieben dass es wieder passt so jetzt haben
wir die richtigen icons oder backes weg leute ich kann jetzt überall auf die leiste klicken
und es schaltet um so jetzt haben wir die leiste dann hier das brauche ich das brauche
ich colors und für transparenz und das da und tray output eigentlich brauche ich alles
eigentlich kann ich das tatsächlich rüber kopieren das ist natürlich doof jetzt dass
ich kein kein vertikel select habe das ist schon blöd jetzt muss ich das immer so machen
man also das ist doof also control v brauche ich doch öfters als gedacht stimmt meine
eindrückung nicht und wie wir alle wissen nicht nicht stimmende eindrückung sind hardcore
cringe so muss das muss ordentlich aussehen so das kommt weg und jetzt refreshen wir mal
jetzt haben wir es oben und wir haben transparenz exzellent so ist das schon viel besser guck
mal jetzt haben wir ordentlich transparenz da oben so jetzt können wir mal gucken was
haben wir denn noch für module so datetime richtig wobei wir können wir können das
doch ohne problem in eine zeile machen oder man solange ist das jetzt nett ich habe es
vier und zwei eingerückt das stimmt das ist nicht nicht nicht so schön es ist gekonert
uhrzeit ne ne ne guck mal es ist gekonert datum und gekonert uhrzeit das müssen wir
schon mal das müssen wir schon mal umstellen das ist das ist nix das ist gar nix ne ne
lass mal kurz usage gucken ob ich irgendwelche den intervall was ist der intervall in was
ist der default intervall advanced usage intervall fünf sekunden ja was ist denn so was ist
der intervall einmal in der sekunde anscheinend sonst wird sie nicht updaten ok das lese
ich mir irgendwann einmal durch wenn ich da zeit zeit und bock drauf hab so also cpu
usage modules nicht cpu ist datetime haben datetime format kann man angeben guck mal
man kann sagen datetime format lokal tüse ok das kann man machen ich bin mir nur nicht
ganz sicher wie die lokale dafür dafür lautet ist wahrscheinlich nicht de oder ne hab ich
gar nicht hab ich gar nicht installiert ok da muss ich muss ich das muss ich von hand
muss ich von hand eingeben also datetime format da muss ich gucken wie man das wie man das
richtig formatiert das ist python striptime alles klar zeige es als unix timestamp an
high fat time ja so so machen wir das ich rechne ich rechne es schnell um so format also ok
in welchem in welchem format wollen wir das haben wir wollen das haben in tag monat ja
in 24 stunden uhr also wollen wir haben m dd mm oder sowas mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert
die dd mm ah ne das ist minute moment mm ist minute ach ne wir haben ja auch januar
wir haben ja auch januar wir haben ja auch wir haben ja auch januar ne passt schon monat
ok das das das ist aber schon zweistellig das heißt wir brauchen das nur einmal ok 23
der erste doppelpunkt ne wobei nicht doppelpunkt doppelpunkts bei der urzeit punkt und was
ist ja 23 ne 2 2 jahre auch nicht was ist was ist das ja ah groß groß ist y das ist
gut 23 der 1. 2023 gefolgt von jetzt ist es wahrscheinlich minute stunde ne moment nicht
mit stunde stunde minute lull bis sie falsch rum 20 45 ja das ist doch nice brauchen wir
die sekunden kommen kommen wir mal die sekunden auch noch rein es ist einfach ein s ja schick
so so gefällt mir das und was mich triggert was mich moment 20 uhr 45 ne das ist richtig
was mit die wochentag interessiert mich nicht wochentag das weiß ich auch so brauche ich
nicht datum mit datum interessiert mich deutlich deutlich mehr als der wochentag wobei mein
wir können die macht man den weekday s locals vollnehmen ok also prozent a könnte man da
noch davor machen hat man jetzt monday drinne stehen ne wir sparen zeichen kalender woche
älter wo wo wo was ist haben die so was überhaupt wie heißt kalender kalender woche überhaupt
auf auf englisch das hier minus fau oder ja vierte kw wetter brauchen wir nicht aber
dann mache ich mondag weg kw wen who cares seriously wen juckt wen juckt kw kw ist auf
ist doch zu 99 prozent irrelevant was interessiert dich wann was für eine kw gerade ist prozent
d ist der wochentag als kürzel nope ist es nicht d ist das datum wochentag kürzel war
klein a ja so ist ok so kann ich damit leben das ist in ordnung was mich triggert ist guckt
mal wir haben da so ein seht ihr das font ob hier das mal hier runter da kann man nämlich
den den font unabhängig davon muss ich auch mal ein bisschen aufräumen das viel zeug
zeug drin da können wir den font nämlich unabhängig mal davon groß machen 32 ach
nee bei 32 ist da kein abstand mehr dazwischen aber bei 12 guckt mal bei 12 ist da so ein
abstand dazwischen und so abstände so pixel abstände die triggern mich immer richtig
ok das ist das ist die abgedrehteste schreibweise die ich da gesehen habe für für kalender
und sowas kw 4.2 ist dienstag in kalender woche 4 alter wer macht denn so was ist das
vom symbol das ist das das ist im thema ist wahrscheinlich so ein trenner drinne wobei
es ja nicht immer gleich ist also anscheinend nicht guck mal wenn ich 13 mach dann stimmt
es nicht so ganz aber mal gucken wir probieren wir müssen hier gleich einen anderen font
ausprobieren so aber das finde ich das finde ich schon mal ganz hübsch so wie das jetzt
ist mit dem montag montag 23 der erste 2023 2049 und 18 und 19 20 sekunden wir gucken
mal was gibt es noch für schöne was gibt es was gibt es noch für module also datetime
ganz rechts finde ich finde ich sehr sinnvoll so was haben wir als nächstes disk usage
ist immer nice dies und da geht da geht der feil manager auf wenn man das anklickt ok
disk open als parameter ich will dass da gar nichts aufgeht wenn ich da drauf klicke kann
man es einfach so überschreiben dem ich einfach sagen disk open ist null diskraum ist null
easy so jetzt ist ausgeschaltet was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten keys ok einfach mal
just for fun ausprobieren keys was man sieht was ich tippe unable to load modules ok nice
da wäre es jetzt natürlich gut zu wissen was natürlich nicht dabei steht was blöd
ist man braucht garantiert irgendeine dependency davon die nicht dabei steht dies das liegt
fast weiter stimmt ich will es aber trotzdem ausprobieren modules
irgendwie was was was das braucht an an dependencies oder so ap reference ja man weiß es nicht
hier steht hier steht nur requires hier gibt es für keys gibt es kein requires anscheinend
braucht man da aber ja irgendwas für auf der webseite stand wie wirklich wo wo steht
hier was du meinst hier im im im github bei keys es müsste ja hier irgendwo drinne stehen
ok unusable to load modules gut ich denke wir verwenden das nicht modules so also wo sind
stehen geblieben. Keys, funktioniert schon mal nett, nice.
Was wäre so top drei Tipps für neue Entwickler von dir,
mit irgendwas anfangen, was man gerne machen will. Also wenn du irgendein Projekt im Kopf hast,
wo du sagst, ey, da habe ich schon lange die Idee oder jetzt hatte ich gerade ganz frisch die Idee, das wäre eine coole Anwendung,
sich dafür dann was suchen, womit man es gut umsetzen kann.
Also sprich nicht nur, weil ich sage, es lohnt sich oftmals mit Javascript und Browser, HTML, CSS anzufangen,
ist es nicht unbedingt sinnvoll. Wenn du jetzt ein Projekt im Kopf hast, dass du sagst, ey, ich würde unglaublich gerne,
keine Ahnung, meine Pumpe fernsteuern oder so, dann stab dir irgendein ESP oder ein Arduino und Platform IOWN und fang damit an.
Das beste ist das, was dir was bringt.
Okay, Layout,
Tastatur Layout. Ich glaube, Tastatur Layout ist nicht so sinnvoll. Ich meine, ich habe DE No Dead Keys fertig, das weiß ich, ich habe auch nur, ups, ich habe auch nur ein Tastatur Layout überhaupt installiert.
Also da muss ich mir keine großen Gedanken drum machen. Load, Load ist natürlich praktisch, Load,
Load und als nächstes gibt es bestimmt auch, gibt es bestimmt auch CPU.
Jawoll und, und Memory. Also wir machen CPU, Load, Disk und dazwischen machen wir Memory.
Ja, das ist gut. Es ist gut, dass die Dinger so benannt sind, wie ich es erwarten würde. Das ist I3, ja.
Hast du schon mal mit Kamunda gearbeitet? Der Name, ich habe das irgendwo,
ich habe den Namen irgendwo mal gehört. Ich kann es aber nicht zuordnen, was es ist.
Das ist I3.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen auf, überladen jetzt, oder? Wobei es geht, weil die Sachen abwechselnd sind. Also sprich mal, wir haben Load,
CPU, Load, Memory und danach Disk.
Wobei ich gar keine Schmerzen habe, wenn Disk und Memory in einem wären und man draufklicken müsste oder sowas.
Aber okay, ist es nicht, ist aber nicht schlimm.
Aber ist aber dann verkehrt. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch Interessantes? Nick?
Nö, brauche ich nicht. Brauche keine Anzeige, was ich für eine IP habe. Egal, Ping brauche ich auch nicht. Audio will ich auch nicht steuern.
Wofür ist Load? Nee, das ist die Load-Seh-... Du meinst, Load, was das bedeutet?
Also Load ist aufgeteilt unter Linux in so drei Bereiche. Das sind, glaube ich, eine Minute, fünf Minuten, zehn Minuten?
Ich bin mir da aus dem Kopf gar nicht so sicher. Das ist, wie war die CPU-Auslastung über die letzte Minute,
über die letzten fünf Minuten und über die letzten zehn Minuten. Ganz easy, ich zeige es dir.
Ja, Press. Ah ja, aber das nicht installiert.
Guck, wenn ich jetzt mal volle, volle CPU-Last mache,
auf allen Kern, dann sieht man, CPU-Last geht instant auf 100%.
Oh, die Icons sind ein bisschen klein.
Die Icons sind ein bisschen klein.
Und du wirst sehen, jetzt geht die Load langsam hoch.
Das hier ist die Load über fünf Minuten, äh die Load über eine Minute, das ist die Load über fünf Minuten,
das ist die Load über zehn oder fünfzehn Minuten, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Das heißt, du kannst eine Load ganz gut erkennen, wenn du aufs System drauf guckst, die Load ist hoch,
aber die CPU-Last ist unten, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, ok, entweder hatte das Ding relativ viel CPU-Last,
eben die letzten paar Minuten über, oder es hängt irgendwo anders.
Also zum Beispiel, du hast eine super langsame Platte und ganz viel wartet darauf, bis sie davon lesen kann.
Da kann die Load auch hochgehen. In der Regel, so die Hausnummer sagt man, glaube ich, Load darf,
also Load, das Max, das Doppelte von der Kernanzahl ist ok, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe,
aber normalerweise hast du damit überhaupt keine Probleme mehr heute, weil deine Kisten alle massig viel Kerne haben.
Guck, jetzt siehst du, es geht hoch, jetzt siehst du, es geht hoch, ich habe jetzt quasi über eine Minute 100% CPU-Auslastung gehabt,
jetzt geht natürlich die Load über die letzte Minute und ein paar Minuten auch, und du wirst sehen,
wenn ich es ausmache, die CPU-Auslastung geht sofort runter, Load über die Minute geht aber langsamer runter.
Also daran kann man auch erkennen, ok, das ist schon ein bisschen länger am abkacken.
Warum nutzt du i3? Weil es das einzige...
Ja, Window-Manager im Endeffekt ist, ich wollte Desktop-Umgebung sagen, ist es aber nicht,
weil es der einzige Window-Manager ist bzw. der einzige Desktop unter Linux, der mich nicht abfackt.
Openbox geht auch noch oder Fluxbox oder so, das ist auch noch ok, aber ganz ehrlich, alles andere nervt mich.
Alles andere nervt mich, ja es gibt noch ein paar andere Tiling-Manager, die auch ganz cool sind,
aber alles andere nervt mich, also GNOME nervt mich, KDE nervt mich, XFCE nervt mich auch irgendwo,
aber das geht noch halbwegs, Mate nervt mich, Cinnamon nervt mich, Batschi, Dingsgeduld nervt mich, nervt mich alles.
i3 nervt mich wahrscheinlich am wenigsten, weil i3 eben keine...
Weil i3 quasi nichts hat außer Fenster im Fullscreen.
Weil man kann Fenster natürlich auch so machen, wenn man die ein bisschen bewegen möchte, ja.
Geht auch, aber will man da eigentlich normalerweise nicht. Lohnt es sich das auszubringen? Ich finde, das ist das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Da oben, was ist denn das?
Broken, null.
Und es läuft halt super performant auch in der VM, was für mich wichtig ist.
So, also CPU-Load-Memory, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Pulse-Audio juckt mich gar nicht, Redshift juckt mich auch nicht, Scroll juckt mich auch nicht, Sensors 2 juckt mich auch nicht.
Aha, ein Spacer.
Moment, kommt durch den Spacer vielleicht dieser komische Abstand?
Spacer?
Äh, warte mal, mal hier davor.
Nee, daher kommt nicht der Abstand.
Das liegt, das liegt am Font.
Außerdem sind die Icons, sind die Icons zu klein.
Wir wollen Font-Hack
Not-Font haben.
Dann sieht es zumindest schon mal ein bisschen gescheit aus.
Yep.
Ah, ach Mist, guck mal, ist immer noch da, ist immer noch da.
Okay.
Speed-Test brauchen wir nicht, Time haben wir.
Vault, okay, Raten brauchen wir nicht.
Sound-Lautstärke, Abt brauchen wir nicht.
Arch-Update, das ist interessant.
Arch-Update.
Zeigt es mir an, wenn es Package-Updates gibt?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Arch-Update.
Und?
Update. Und?
Klappt nicht.
Warum nicht, weil?
Ah, ich muss, ich muss Pac-Man-Contrip installieren, okay.
Pac-Man-Contrip.
Das da muss ich wohl installieren anscheinend, aha aha aha.
Geht es jetzt?
Hey!
Guck mal, ich habe eine Update-Anzeige, das ist ja nice.
Das war eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich meine, wir müssen den Platz hier oben irgendwie füllen.
So, jetzt gucken wir auch mal, ob das automatisch weggeht.
Pac-Man.
System, System-Update machen.
Updates durchgeführt und jetzt, und jetzt.
Und jetzt, geht es jetzt weg?
Weird-Champ.
Geht nicht von alleine.
Ich kann euch sagen, dass ich meine Leiste reloaden muss, dass es weggeht.
Das wäre doch bescheuert.
Soll gefälligst von alleine weggehen.
Nee, nee, so ist das nix.
Fünf Minuten Reload wäre aber auch ganz schön, ganz schön weird.
Oder eine Minute oder so vielleicht, aber.
Eine Minute, wir geben ihm mal kurz eine Minute Zeit.
Wir gucken mal, was wir als nächstes ausprobieren.
Ach so, ist, okay, das ist doof.
Das Arch- und User-Repo-Update nicht in einem ist.
Das ist blöd.
Da lasse ich das selbst, da lasse ich das bleiben.
Ich meine, ich fühle eh meistens alle eins, zwei Tage mal so einen,
so einen Update aus.
Okay, Batterie haben wir nicht.
Batterie, Batterie, Batterie.
Bluetooth brauchen wir nicht.
Blue, äh, Blue Gone.
Brightness brauchen wir nicht.
Media Player brauchen wir nicht.
Currency.
Kann man seine Stonks umrechnen.
Date, Time, TZ, Displays.
Nö, passt.
Alles, alles gut.
Stimmt ja hier.
1, 2, 0, 2, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Dates, Dead Beef brauchen, DNF, Docker, PS.
Okay, warum nicht?
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind,
sollten wir das bei der Gelegenheit auch mal kurz installieren.
Weil das werden wir auf jeden Fall brauchen.
Docker, PS, ach nee.
Ich muss in die Docker Group und ich muss Docker erst mal starten.
System, System, CTL, Status, Docker.
Is disabled, enable und starten.
Starten, was?
Starten, Alter.
Docker, PS, Funst.
Docker, PS, Funst nicht.
Weil ich nicht in der Docker Gruppe bin.
Nee, nicht PassWD.
Group.
Enable now.
Five Head Kommando.
Ich muss in die Docker Group.
Irgendjemand planen, wie ich User Berechtigung neu lade,
ohne meine X-Session neu zu starten?
Geht das? Gibt es da so was wie?
Also, ich meine, ich könnte mich neu einloggen.
Das würde funktionieren.
Also, ich kann so eine neue Logging-Geschichte starten.
Das funktioniert, glaube ich.
Was?
Ja, funktioniert, okay.
Habe ich einen Bug in meiner Bash-RC?
Oder woran stört das sich jetzt?
Das ist komplett...
Also, es ist fast alles default in meiner Bash-RC.
Soll ich vielleicht die Alias da vormachen?
Nee, hier dran stört das sich.
Ja, der hat irgendeinen Schmerzen an meiner Bash-RC.
Wobei, die Bash-RC ist default.
Da habe ich gar nichts gemacht.
Also, daran stört das sich wohl.
Wobei, warum?
Nee, okay, dann.
What ever.
Ist mir egal.
Wir müssen eh auf ZSH nachher umsteigen.
Dann juckt es mich nicht mehr.
Okay, alles klar.
Also, Docker hat funktioniert.
Wunderbar.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Notifications juckt mich nicht.
Notifications brauche ich nicht.
Warum nicht Fisch?
Weil ich keinen Bock habe mich an neue Shell zu gewöhnen.
Google-Kalender brauche ich auch nicht.
Get-Krypto.
Das ist für die ganzen Kryptobros unter uns.
Die können sich das einplanen.
Lass gleich den Bitcoin-Kurs oben in deiner Leiste drin.
Okay, das Update update nicht.
Das sackt, das fliegt wieder raus.
Also, seriously.
Ein Update war sich nicht automatisch updated, wenn geupdatet wurde.
Aber lass mal mal kurz.
Also, ja, jetzt ist es auch weg.
Ist es gerade von alleine weggegangen?
Bevor ich reloaded hab, hat es wahrscheinlich wirklich 5 Minuten Refresh-Time?
Ich glaube, es ist gerade ganz kurz weggegangen.
Bevor ich refreshed hab, ne?
Okay, das geht, das geht.
Aber trotzdem, das brauche ich nicht.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Das ist unsinnig.
Okay, GitHub-Sachen kann es anzeigen.
Was?
GPMD, Google Music Player, HDD Temperature.
Brauche ich nicht Hostname, brauche ich auch nicht.
HTTP-Status von der Seite.
Unsinnig.
Indicator.
Indicator für was?
Indicator, ob Caps Lock gepresst ist.
Okay, das finde ich zum Beispiel interessant.
Indicator.
Num Lock.
So, ich presse mal Num Lock.
Der checkt das.
Cool.
Okay, Caps Lock habe ich umgemappt.
Den gibt es nicht mehr.
Haben wir denn Parameter?
Hier, Indicator include.
Indicator include.
Und dann will ich nämlich nur Num Lock include.
Kann man das vielleicht hier dahinter machen?
Dann sieht man es besser.
Include Num Lock.
Okay, ich fürchte.
Man muss alles hintereinander hier machen.
Man kann das nicht zwischendurch machen.
Ja.
Aber guck mal, jetzt habe ich einen Num Lock Indicator.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Wenn man sich mal irgendwie fragt, so ist das an oder ist das aus, kann man da oben hingucken.
Sehr cool.
Lassen wir es mal an.
Ich mag Num Lock.
Weil wenn da Num Lock an ist, kann man sowas machen.
Deswegen kaufe ich mir auch nur Tastaturen mit kompletter Breite und Num Lock.
Also Indicator ist schon mal nice.
Meine Tastatur hat keine Num Lock Anzeige.
Das ist gerade der Witz da dran.
Das haben die sich gespart bei Logitech.
Die haben sich gedacht, Num Lock, obwohl da oben massig Platz ist, da könnten ohne Probleme
noch ein Num Lock LED hin.
Gibt es aber nicht.
Die ganze Tastatur hat LED Beleuchtung.
Aber eine Num Lock LED oben rechts.
Ne.
Legacy Feature.
Braucht man nicht.
They Out Switch brauchen wir auch nicht.
Lip Wirth VMs brauchen wir auch nicht.
Message Receiver.
Displays, Messages, Receive via Unix Socket.
Wait a minute.
Was?
Kann man das Sachen reinpipen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Message Receiver.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Also ich brauche eine andere Schriftart.
Diese zwischendrin, diese Sachen, die nicht pixelgenau sind, die Träger an mich.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Wohin muss ich was schreiben?
Temp?
Dahin?
No such file.
Das ist auch toll.
Nice.
Poggers.
Habe ich SoCat überhaupt installiert?
Können wir mal machen.
Vielleicht brauche ich das auch als Echo oder irgendetwas.
No such file or directory.
Yeah.
Super.
Und weiter?
Habe ich...
Ach nee, Parameter.
Ach, ich brauche den Parameter, wo das Socket dann liegt.
Ah ja.
Okay, okay.
Das habe ich falsch verstanden.
Wir machen die Parameter doch mal auf eine extra Zeile.
Geht es noch?
Ja.
Also jetzt brauche ich sowas wie Parameter.
Ups.
Nochmal Parameter.
Message receiver.
Und jetzt will ich sowas haben wie hier Gleich, Temp.
Was hat denn sich hier drinnen als Beispiel?
Message receiver SoC.
Wunderbar.
Das will ich haben.
Und jetzt machen wir das Ganze noch mal.
Und es geht immer noch nicht.
No such file or directory.
Der legt das einfach nicht an.
Aber ich habe doch schon Rechte auf TMP.
Das würde mich sehr wundern, wenn ich...
Touch.
Eins.
Jo.
Geht.
Habe ich das falsch gehört?
Parameter.
Message receiver.
Gleich.
Ach.
Ich muss das bestimmt quoteen.
Ich muss das bestimmt.
Wer weiß, was der jetzt...
Wo und was der jetzt angelegt hat.
Immer noch nicht.
Fuck.
Okay.
Muss ich es vielleicht initial einmal anlegen oder so?
Jetzt bin ich überfragt, wie das funktioniert.
Wie erstellt man sowas überhaupt?
Mit Touch wird es ja nicht sein.
Da muss man irgendwie MK-Dings...
Schau mal, wo man hinkommt bei dem Link.
Auf das Guitar-Profil von dem Dude, der es Contributed hat.
Alter, da will ich hin.
Bam.
Connection Refused, ja ach.
Es ist ja auch eine Text-Datei.
Habe ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht oder so?
Okay, jetzt...
Message.
Das wäre nämlich eine mega nice Geschichte, wenn das funktioniert.
Message-Receiver.
Ich habe die Anzeige schon neu gestartet.
Tja, man weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Message-Receiver.
Create SOC-Pile.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
So ist der Name Pipe, das ist was anderes.
Normalerweise, soweit ich weiß, musst du das gar nicht anlegen.
Weil beim ersten Zugriff wird das angelegt.
Aber so wie es aussieht, scheint das nicht...
Moment.
What the fuck?
Was ist denn da los?
Das ist jetzt 30 Milliarden Mal angelegt.
Oder wie?
Moment.
Das geht ja so nett.
Ja, das ist das Zeug, das ich angelegt habe.
Ich glaube, ich benutze das irgendwie falsch.
Wobei, Status.
Ja, das macht das irgendwie verkehrt.
Ich nenne es jetzt mal Kekkel-Punkt-SOC.
Restart.
Es gibt keinen Kekkel-Punkt-SOC.
Okay, dann bin ich zu dumm dafür.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Macht es vielleicht irgendwelche...
Wie ist es denn, wenn ich das von Hand starte?
Wirft das irgendwelche Errors oder so vielleicht?
Wirft das irgendwelche Errors, Debug oder...
Import.
Critical.
Import failed, not found.
Daran wird es wahrscheinlich liegen.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, ist, was genau ist not found?
Also, what exactly?
Import failed, not found.
Module.
Ja, okay.
Und was?
Ist ja nicht ganz unerheblich zu wissen, was.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Wir machen mal Message-Receiver weg und gucken, ob dann die Fehlermeldung immer noch kommt.
Nee, okay, die Fehlermeldung kommt immer noch.
Nee, die Meldung kommt immer noch, dann ist es egal.
Okay, ja, dann bin ich überfragt, wie das funktionieren soll mit dem Message-Receiver.
Das ist doof, weil das wäre ein wirklich cooles Feature gewesen, was mir gefällt.
Ich kann es mal, ich kann es mal in meinem Heimatverzeichnis erstellen lassen.
Home Max.
Nö.
Minus M?
Hab ihn da.
Moment.
So, ich wollte ihn nur mit einer Teil löschen, die Minus M heißt.
Nö, der erstellt einfach keinen Sockel.
Okay, dann bin ich zu blöd dafür, das ordentlich zu bedienen.
Message-Receiver ist broken.
Könnte sein, dass es vielleicht auch daran liegt.
Nee, okay, jetzt fällt mir nichts mehr ein.
Was, du hast das doch mit dem Message-Receiver gestartet?
Ja, zur Absicht oder wie jetzt?
So cut.
No such file or directory.
Achja, ach.
Nö, geht nicht.
Okay, dann habe ich keinen Plan, wie es funktioniert.
Ich meine, die Anzeige ist jetzt auch nicht so, da gibt es nicht so viel.
Aber es wäre wirklich cool, wenn das funktioniert mit dem Sommer.
Dann kann ich da oben irgendwelche Status-Meldungen anzeigen.
Das wäre schon äußerst pog.
Ich meine, es ist auch sehr übersichtlich hier.
So cut.
Create as.
Listen.
Da kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen, oder?
Kann das sein, dass ich irgendwie die falsche Syntax habe dafür?
Da gibt es ja auch kein richtiges, kein richtiges Example.
Das gibt es auch schon eine Weile.
Da gab es ja auch kein richtiges Example für Test-Message-Receiver.
Ah, guck mal.
Da können wir mal gucken, was...
Ah Mist, ich dachte, es gibt einen Test vielleicht dafür.
Okay, dann habe ich keine Ahnung.
Komm mit.
Das ist auch schon, das ist auch 20 Jahre, 20 Jahre, drei Jahre schon drinnen.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie man das, wie man das zum Laufen bekommen möchte.
Gut, dann lassen wir das bleiben.
Können wir da ewig mehr drum machen.
Also einzige Sache, die mir noch einfällt, ist, ich mache mal wirklich alles weg.
Wow.
Okay, die Wim-Config ist doof.
Ich hätte jetzt, ich hätte eigentlich erwartet, wenn ich, dass der Zeilenumbruch macht.
Also wir machen mal, wir machen, wir machen mal alles andere weg.
Vielleicht, vielleicht bringt das ja was.
Parameter, Indicator.
Ich habe ja meine Wim-Historie schon, hoffe ich, aktiviert.
Da gibt es keine Fehler jetzt.
Ach so.
Ich hätte es gar nicht löschen müssen.
Ich kann es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Wenn ich hier alles lösche, außer das.
Moment, ist es, ist es vielleicht nicht, muss ich irgendwie was mit Punkt dazwischen machen?
Message Receiver, Punkt, irgendetwas.
Ist die, sind die Docs einfach nur kacke?
Na das ist natürlich Müll, wenn man sich durch den Source-Code kämpfen muss, damit man, damit man versteht, versteht, wie es funktioniert.
Message, Message Receiver.
Okay, er hat einen Taipo gefixt.
Sekunde.
Nicht, dass er einen Bug reingebracht hat, den man den Taipo gefixt hat.
Ach so.
Okay, er hat einen Taipo in einem Comment gefixt.
Na ja gut, das wäre.
Ja, das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht gewesen sein.
Parameters.
Moment, Address heißt das?
Address?
What the fuck?
Es ist Message Receiver Punkt Address.
Alter, wer soll denn bitte schön da drauf kommen?
Da musst du in den Source-Code gucken, dass du das verstehst.
Okay, mir war nachher gleich Pullgequest auf.
Pass mal auf, jetzt geht's.
Nee.
Geht nicht.
Also es ist Message Receiver Punkt Address.
Das sieht man ja hier, weil Parameter Address.
Ich würde jetzt eigentlich erwarten, dass das so funktioniert.
Ach Moment, ich mache es ja auch in Temp.
Temp.
Jetzt geht's.
Okay, jetzt alles klar.
Na gut, man muss es.
Aber das ist wirklich Mist.
Wer soll denn das noch checken?
So, jetzt können wir es nämlich auch so lassen.
Wir wissen, dass es Message Punkt Address ist.
Perfekte Dogs.
Pogu Dogs.
So, Cut.
Moment.
Das ist das Falsche.
Wir müssen jetzt Connection Refused.
Hat es jetzt gerade was angezeigt?
Oder nicht?
Hat es irgendwas angezeigt?
Ist das verbackt oder was?
Was ist das hier?
Funktioniert ja exzellent.
Exquisite.
Die Quotes sind auch kaputt.
Die Quotes sind auch kaputt, man.
Nee, geht aber nicht.
Filename ist falsch.
Nee, Filename ist.
Kommst du drauf, dass Filename falsch ist?
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt funktioniert's.
Okay, nachdem ich das gefixt habe, geht's.
Okay, das heißt, wir können jetzt ein Herzchen reinmachen.
Okay, ist praktisch.
Was macht man in State?
Was schickt man in State mit?
Color oder sowas?
Ich habe übrigens einen Bug gefunden.
Die haben einen Try Catch wahrscheinlich verpasst.
Wenn es einen Fehler gibt, dann kackt das Ding ab.
Okay, aber das ist praktisch.
Das ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Kann man bestimmt noch gebrauchen.
A State Warning.
Das kann man für Skript verwenden.
Gibt es auch noch etwas wie Error?
Leute, woher wisst ihr, dass es Warning als State gibt?
Wo habt ihr das her?
Ach so, das ist ein Beispiel.
Wie viele States A-P-Referenz.
State wäre natürlich auch zu einfach.
Der wertet State gar nicht wirklich aus, oder?
Er setzt einfach nur State.
Auf was kann man State setzen?
State?
Was gibt es da?
Ich hätte erwartet, dass sowas z.B. in der A-P-Doc drinne steht.
Macht es aber nicht.
Vielleicht im Output-Module?
State?
Aha.
Warning.
Decorators Warning.
Okay, also die Docs sind definitiv noch verbesserungswürdig.
Decorator, Default zu Warning.
Critical geht auch noch.
Aha.
Das muss man aber sehr um 5 Ecken sich zusammenreimen.
Ist es jetzt röter als sonst?
Das ist noch...
Okay.
Warning ist Orange-Rot und Critical ist Rot.
Alles klar.
Na dann.
Color.
Also wahrscheinlich gibt es nur Critical und Warning, gehe ich mal von aus.
Critical.
Gucken, wo das definiert ist.
Hier.
Nee.
Nick.
Da stand noch Widget-States.
Ach Moment, ich spiele nur wieder eine.
Das wird schon passen.
Nach was muss ich suchen?
Warning.
Was haben wir?
Widget-States.
Ah ja, hier.
Okay.
Es gibt das, was wir...
Okay, das ist auch geile Farbgebung jetzt hier mit dem Dark-Reader.
Also man kann...
Each Widget-Inside-Module can have a list of states for example.
Two predefined states, Warning und Critical.
Okay, es gibt bloß Warning und Critical.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Also was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Das finde ich schon mal sehr cool und praktisch.
Was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Message.
Okay.
Was ist das?
Ach, Musikplayer.
Musikplayer.
Braucht man nicht.
Network.
Braucht man...
Network-Traffic.
Ja, juckt mich nicht.
Not much count.
Was?
Ist das ein...
Ist das ein E-Mail-Anbieter oder was?
Just an E-Mail-System.
Sieht aus wie von 1995.
Muss ja nicht schlecht sein.
Octo-Print kann man...
Gpu-Man...
Pac-Man?
Ach ja.
Pac-Man direkt.
Okay, das ist natürlich nicht verkehrt.
Vielleicht ist das besser als Arch-Update.
Pac-Man direkt.
Null, null, null, null.
Ach, das sind die alten Repos.
Das verschwendet zu viel Platz dafür.
Mixer.
Persian Date.
Piehole.
Player.
Pomodoro.
Oh, ist das ein Timer?
Oh, das ist cool.
So ein Timer?
Kann man immer mal gebrauchen.
Und jetzt?
Ich habe mich irgendwas übersehen?
Machen wir mal hier dazwischen, da ich was sehe.
Pomodoro...
Rarare.
Hä?
Moment.
Warum geht das an der Stelle?
Und an der Stelle...
Ups.
An der Stelle geht es nicht.
Hab ich mich vertippt?
Jetzt geht es.
Okay, es geht.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Guck mal, jetzt hat man einen Timer.
Kann man draufklicken?
Ach.
Ja, okay.
Das ist...
Das...
Ey, das ist mega praktisch.
Ein Timer da oben in der...
In der Status Bar.
Und wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen können?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was passiert, wenn das Ding null erreicht?
Okay.
Work...
Work Duration.
Plinkt das dann?
Nee, das...
Das switcht dann...
Das switcht dann auf...
Auf Pause, wahrscheinlich.
Machen wir mal eine Minute.
Ich glaube, weniger geht nicht.
Okay, kann man vielleicht...
Halbe Minuten oder so?
Nee.
Minute ist...
Minute ist das kleinste, anscheinend.
Okay, mal gucken, was passiert.
Was passiert, wenn es auf null geht?
Break Duration auf Timer in Minutes, 5.
Commodoro Format.
Timer Display...
Minutes, Seconds, ja, das ist okay.
Promodoro Notify.
Hey, wir können uns notifien da lassen über dieses Ding.
Über unsere...
Über unsere Mini-Status-Bar.
Okay, das ist zwar sehr hacky, aber auch irgendwie cool, dass das alles in der Status-Leiste
drin ist.
Okay, 15 Sekunden.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Wahrscheinlich geht es einfach nur auf 5 Minuten jetzt bitte Pause machen.
Okay, 3, 2, 1, Null, Break, okay, jetzt geht das, jetzt zählen die 5 Minuten Break runter.
Also, es ist auch nicht so, dass es blinken würde, wenn ich Stopp mache, okay, also rechte
Mausplasse.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Okay, das heißt, wir machen jetzt hier P, Commodoro Notify und da...
Kann man das überhaupt dann so ausführen hier drinnen?
Da stand doch irgendwen was.
Notify Command Run, wenn der Timer endet.
If you want to chain multiple Commands, please use an external wrapper script.
Ah gut.
By the way, brauche ich so Cat überhaupt?
Kann ich nicht?
Mal kurz was ausprobieren.
Kann ich nicht direkt, direkt da reinpipen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht direkt.
Nee, nee, da kann man nicht direkt reinpipen.
So Cat, kann So Cat irgendwie Embedded den Text bekommen?
So müsste funktionieren, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das da drinnen laufen wird.
Also, das müsste funktionieren ohne Pipe, aber im Prinzip ist es ja das...
Ups.
Im Prinzip ist es ja das gleiche.
Okay, So Cat kann nicht aus der Date...
Kann So Cat aus der Datei lesen?
So Cat?
Moment, ich hab...
Ich hab nicht mal Manpages installiert.
Kann ich alles haben?
FIle? kann das from file lesen?
Netcat.
Netcat minus U, ist Netcat minus U nicht UDP oder ist das socket?
So Cat, read file.
Okay, das muss man standard inpipen, also was meinst du Netcat, haben wir das?
NC?
Alter!
Was ist denn das Gute, ich vergesse es immer.
Welches ist NC und welches ist Netcat?
Ich glaube, das BSD ist das Gute, ja, okay, naja, geht weiter.
Es ist ein Link, NC minus U, was macht der minus U?
Cannot be used with minus U, Unix domain socket, ach ja, das funktioniert auch, also das heißt
im Endeffekt, ich brauche jetzt nicht so Cat, ich kann jetzt sagen Echo, rühren wir das
mal so aus, was ich machen will, ich mache meinen Desktop hübsch, so Echo, das da, nach
NC minus U, Temp, TMP, das darf man nochmal abschreiben, wobei, geht das überhaupt so?
Ja, das geht so, nice, so und jetzt kann Netcat irgendwie einen Input String direkt definieren,
was stört dich an, so Cat, ganz einfach, dass ich keine Pipes verwenden kann, hier
drinne, damit ich da was anzeigen kann, ich meine, ich müsste den Skript irgendwo hinlegen,
was dann ausgeführt wird, das wird gehen, aber es wäre natürlich cool, wenn man das
inline machen kann, aber also, sag mal so, redirect müsste eigentlich funktionieren,
no such file or directory, ja ok, machen wir mal Echo, das da, Pipe mal mal blub.txt, wunderbar
und jetzt müsste ich eigentlich sagen können blub.txt, funktioniert das jetzt, hier ist
der Message, ok, jetzt natürlich die Preisfrage, ob ich, boah, das ist das und alles nur, dass
ich keinen Rapper Skript basteln muss man, ok, das ist bisschen zu abgedreht, ich glaube,
ich mach das einfach in extra Datei und gut ist, NC minus U und jetzt machen wir mal Name
Pipe da draus, hau das hier rein, Port, ich will keinen Port, Alter, so, jetzt haben wir
Input, das wird aber im Leben nicht da drinne funktionieren Leute, im Leben nicht, auf gar
keinen Fall, also das kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dass ich das da einfach
reinkopieren kann und dann funktioniert's, nee, guck mal, allein schon, na gut, ich mein,
wir könnten, ok, ich mein, er frisst's, er frisst's, aber das Zeug ist gar nicht richtig
escaped, das ist überhaupt nicht richtig escaped, mal gucken, was passiert, wenn die Minute
ab runter geht, das Video ist immer noch geplant, ja, das ist doof, dass ich jetzt eine Minute
warten muss, bis ich das sehe, das ist doch, das ist doch Müll, ok, also das wird nicht
funktionieren, guck mal, ich mein, das ist bash, bash, zeug shell redirect, das wird
hier drinnen noch im Leben nicht funktionieren, da müssen wir, machen wir einfach ein Rapper
machen, ich weiß, dass es nicht wirklich gut ist, ich bereite das schon mal vor, einfach
so, ich leg das jetzt mal testweise, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, grepos, vim, das heißt critical
wenn ich dieses ding hier aus ausführen kann ich mein kammer netcat nicht kammer netcat
nicht direkt irgendwie ein input string mitgeben wie input input so direkt ja
filename ja so schlau bin ich auch printf kann man reinpipen
ja gut
das vielleicht
ist das wenn du die inneren escapes stimmt das können wir noch mal probieren den da den da
den da den da die achte das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf den da und den da haben jetzt alles
eskept ok ich klicke noch mal mal gucken was jetzt passiert hat jemand empfehlung für einen
kleinen heimstall server zynology oder anderen anbieter wenn du nicht selbst großartig machen
willst mach einfach mach kauf dir ein fertiges nass gut ist kannst du kannst du ruhig machen
es frücht jetzt nichts dagegen ansonsten wenn du selbst bauen willst ist von intel die in diese
intel power plattform j 4 1 2 5 oder so ist ganz gut hatte ich auch eine weile mal was von dem
einsatz ach ja also man kann trüppel trüppel redirect machen hast du über our installiert
oder geht aber ist das verwandt mit dem bar mit dem mit dem youtuber der aber mal gucken was
passiert 3 2 1 ich tippe auf fehler null und das funktioniert nicht das ganze vergesse
minus minus s h exak sekunde
was
ach moment das ist n map das ist n map was ist denn n cat jetzt schon wieder
was ist die sommer was anderes ok das ist das ist was von das ist was von den n map leuten
das ist ja das ist wieder durch die po ok dann nehmen wir jetzt knu knu net cat das
kann das bestimmt konfliktet ja mir doch egal weg exak wie
requires an argument das ist das ist so mysteriös das ist
aber ist die ist die hilfe vielleicht einfach nur komplett für ein arsch kann das sein
an die programme to execute after connect ok da habe ich das da habe ich jetzt habe ich jetzt
kein bock ich mein theoretisch theoretisch müsste das ja gehen unix socket ist es auch
ist es auch minus u also dass ich quasi sagen kann wir lernen netcat wir lernen netcat dass
ich sagen kann nc-so das funktioniert invalid option minus u aha das funktioniert da schon
mal net socket das ist mir knu netcat unix socket sagt bloß das kann das normale netcat
jetzt wieder nicht ach ok das normale netcat kann kein unix ach du große ne ne ne hör
mal bloß auf reicht mir jetzt reicht mir schon ich mache ich mache da jetzt den rapper
script zu und fertig
lock ok das stunten da und nicht glaub dass das nicht funktioniert nicht ich aber es war
So funktioniert nicht, dann scheiß drauf, dann lassen wir das jetzt mal kurz sein, aber
es wäre natürlich schon nice, wenn man hier drinne dann quasi was hinschicken könnte
zu dieser Message Box, wenn da Timer bimmelt. Das hätte schon irgendwo was. Also komm,
wir machen jetzt einfach da ein kleines Skript. Ne, das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst keine Redirects da drinne verwenden. Ach Leute, ich bin ja blöd. Easy. Wir können
einfach nur schnell aufrufen. Ist doch ganz einfach. Wir machen. Wollen wir mal hier Echo.
Moment. So. Jetzt brauche ich das andere Netcat wieder, weil das Knu Netcat ist jetzt wieder nicht,
nicht, nicht, nicht. Okay, nice. Also ich kann doch jetzt einfach sagen. Minus C. Und dann das
da rein. Eskäpen. Eskäpestellz. Müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren. Basch, Minus. Ja,
ich kann einfach. Ich kann es einfach in der Basch starten. Ja, das dann dann funktioniert
es. Dann ist es einfach. Brauche ich. Wartet mal, wartet mal, wartet mal. Das. Das heißt
jetzt, das wird jetzt ziemlich. Eskäphell mit in den Quotes, Quotes in den Quotes,
in den, die schon eskäpt sind. Das, das, das wird so. Kann ich das nicht vielleicht einfach
weglassen? Geht es dann? Geht es dann vielleicht immer noch? Connection Refuse. Ich habe es. Ich
habe es. Ich habe es gebrägt. Wie kann man dem? Kann man? Nee, man muss es. Man muss es
quaten. Aber ich könnte es so machen. Braucht man für das Echo? Fürs Echo braucht man was.
Aber das Echo können wir eskäpen. Dann brauchen wir hier nichts mehr. Wir können die Klammern
eskäpen. Dann müsste es eigentlich so funktionieren. Fuck. Okay, das schon mal. Oh Shit, man. Ah,
nee. Warte mal, warte mal. Wir haben eh nur noch 10 Minuten Zeit. Das, das muss ich jetzt
rauskriegen. Das nervt mich, dass es nicht geht. Das funktioniert doch. Es funktioniert
doch. Message. Critical. Lieber eine Stunde. Ja, so ist das. Eine Stunde rumprobieren ist
eindeutig der überlegene Move. Ah, das muss gequoted da natürlich rauskommen, sonst wird
das nix. Also muss ich doch eskäpen. Oh Shit, man. Muss ich doch eskäpen. Okay. Es, Escape,
Escape Reno. Okay, okay, Echo. Wie kriege ich, wie kriege ich das jetzt ohne Quotes großartig?
Egal, wir lassen das. So ist okay, so ist okay. Also NC minus U. Bei State fehlt ein Quote.
Ach hier. Ah ja, dann funktioniert es. Okay, okay, okay. So und jetzt NC minus U nach TMP.
Okay, da muss ich mal kurz hochscrollen, was jetzt ja wieder mit der Maus gescheit funktioniert.
Okay, das funktioniert. Zeigte an. Okay, nice. Und das und das am besten jetzt noch. Warum
beendet sich netcat eigentlich nicht? Kann sich netcat nicht nach einer Zeit selbst beenden?
Netcat Auto Exit nach irgendwie 1, 2 Sekunden oder so. Minus Q. Minus Q, was? Quit Timer
Invalid. Quit Timer Invalid. Okay. Und dann? Wenn der Quit Timer Invalid ist? Minus W geht
auch. Minus W. Invalid Timeout. Minus W1. Ah ja, ah ja, alles klar. So, jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt. Zack. Bash minus D. Das Dumme ist, wir müssten das hier jetzt multi-escapen.
Ist das eklig. Ich glaube, man kann hier drinnen keine doppelten Quotes verwenden für Strings
oder kann man in der i3-Config doppelte Quotes für Strings verwenden? Wahrscheinlich. Gucken
wir mal. Das wird ja wahrscheinlich ein Syntax-Syntax-Fehler schmeißen. Nee? Aber es funktioniert
nicht. Normalerweise sollte jetzt was mit Resize kommen. Ja, ja, nee, nee. Kann ich
mal please wieder in irgendeinem funktionierenden Zustand kommen? So, Resize. Ob das jetzt funktioniert?
Ich hab da meine Zweifel. Das ist ja hier komplett, komplett Escape Hell. Guck mal hier.
Wir starten in Bash minus C. Echo minus Dings. Escaped, Klammern. Da blickste, da blickste
ja nicht mehr durch. So. Aber das escapte hier kommt wahrscheinlich in der Bash gar
nicht mehr an. Weil wahrscheinlich, also wahrscheinlich müssten wir sowas hier machen.
Also das wird escaped. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Ich muss es
escapte escapten wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich muss ich sowas hier machen. Ach du Scheiße.
Mir wäre es eigentlich ganz lieb, wenn ich das irgendwie ohne Double Quotes hinbekommen
würde. Aber ich glaube das hat es funktioniert Leute. Aber es ist auch nicht abgekackt. Hat
es was gemacht gerade? Hat nicht funktioniert. Es ist wahrscheinlich einfach die Bash abgekackt
und ja. Ein eigenes Skript ist doch einfach. Ja das ist einfacher. Da hast du schon recht.
Das einfachste wäre ich mache einen Einzeiler Rapper Skript und gut ist. Aber ich will wissen
wie man das inline macht. Das sind so Sachen die ich aus Prinzip wissen will. Nicht weil
es irgendwie großartig Sinn machen würde. Ok wie könnte man diesen Shit irgendwie anders
schreiben so dass ich nicht so viel escapten muss. 6 6 Head Time. Das können wir weg machen.
So jetzt sind da nämlich die Quotes nicht drin. Ok also wir können sowas hier machen.
Da machen wir Single Quotes drum dann ist das schonmal für die Shell kein Problem. Moment
die macht das die Escaptors trotzdem. Jetzt hatte ein rot gesagt ja weil ich es von Hand
ausgeführt habe gerade. Warum sind da jetzt keine Quotes mit drin? Also muss ich es doch
so machen. Alter ich raste aus. Das ist doch kacke man. Das ist doch Müll. Das funktioniert
auch so nett. So ist gut. So ist nice. Aber sobald ich das in der Shell packe. Ach Mensch
mir fällt jetzt nichts gescheites ein. Ich mein Moment. Wir müssen das ja nicht mit
Echo machen. Der Text ändert sich ja nicht. Der Text ist ja statisch. Können wir den
Text in der Environment variablen? Ne das geht nicht. Ich kann keine Redirektion verkennen.
Wenn ich es in der Datei schreibe dann bringt das nichts. Wenn ich es in der Datei schreibe
dann kann ich es auch gleich in Wrapperskrippen machen. Ok wir könnten sagen Base64. Wir könnten
sagen Base64 und dann Base64 Decode. Also wir könnten es als Base64 nehmen. Also quasi
so. Jetzt wird es High IQ. Also wir brauchen hier gar nichts eskaten. Minus D passt wunderbar
und das palten wir jetzt nach Netcat. Funktioniert. Funktioniert. Ok Base64 ist unsere Rettung.
Base64. Jetzt können wir natürlich den Input nicht mal gescheit ändern. Aber ok das ist
ja erstmal egal. Wir könnten auch ein Inline Python machen. Weil das kann ja Triple Quotes
und was Triple Quotes kann wird auch funktionieren. Bloß Double Quotes darf ich nicht verwenden
weil dann mein E3 Config am abscheißen ist. So und jetzt sage ich Bash minus C und da komplett
drum herum Quotes. Und wenn ich Glück habe funktioniert das. Jawoll funktioniert. Ok
und das kann ich jetzt höchstwahrscheinlich auch da rein kopieren und es funktioniert
einfach. Ok easy. Schauen wir mal. Also das ist jetzt wirklich so How to wie sollte man
es eher nicht machen. Aber ich mein warum nicht gucken wir mal. Es ist wirklich blöd
dass ich immer eine Minute warten muss bis ich ausprobieren kann. So Chat was meint
ihr funktioniert's. Also ich tippe drauf die Chancen stehen gut. Es ist so ein Zwischending
es ist 5 Head dass es geht es ist ziemlich 3 Head dass man es so macht. Drei Kopf. Es
ist 99 Prozent 5 Head und 1 Prozent 2 Head schon fast. Ok 5 4 3 2 1 ok und und es geht
es geht es funktioniert. Hi IQ Lösung. Ich mein eigentlich will ich da gar kein A drinne
anzeigen. Ja denn A ist ziemlich hängen geblieben. Aber es funktioniert. Es funktioniert. Wir
können noch was wir was alle heißen. One Liner Output Text. Das weiß ich nämlich nicht wie
das geht. Kann man das nicht online. One Line. One Liner. Das muss man auch mit Minus M irgendwie
machen. Ah ne Minus C ist es. Minus C ist es ok. Ja gut das ist. Rind. Zwei so ne. Ja
das funktioniert. So weil ich glaube ich glaube ich kann jetzt in Python sowas hier machen.
Dumm dumm dumm. Lul V dumm dumm dumm. Was? Name Lul V not defined. Oh ne muss ich trotzdem
wieder es kennen. Ah shit. Ich muss da ich muss da. Ne muss ich. Geht das vielleicht
ganz ohne. Ne geht auch nicht ganz ohne. Das ist ein Kommentar. Ne. Das ist das ist das
ist ganz normale Python String Syntax. Das ist so String Literals. Da kannst du auch
New Lines und so rein machen. Das funktioniert dann immer noch. Ok das funktioniert nicht
weil ich brauche in dem Fall die Single Quotes. Das heißt überhaupt Rist. Ne das bringt
nix. Double Quotes bringt nix. Die brauche ich für die Config. Ich darf keine Double
Quotes verwenden. Weil ansonsten ist es kaputt bzw. ich weiß nicht wie man es escapen muss.
Wir können es ja mal ausprobieren. Eko. Wo ist denn jetzt der Text den man eigentlich
ausgeben wollen. Hier. So. So. Moment. What? Das ist weil es keine. Oh kacke. Das funktioniert
nicht so wie ich will. Hat Preiss nicht noch irgendeine andere String Syntax. Gibt es
da nicht noch irgendwie was anderes Backticks oder sowas vielleicht. Irgendwas anderes
noch. Ne anscheinend kannst du nur. Dann funktioniert das funktioniert nicht. Ok das ist blöd. Dann
das ist das ist Dorf. Ne ne dann funktioniert es. Du kannst mir Jake Hune und Jason ausgeben.
Ok ne das ist blöd. Ich mein das hier oben hat schon was mit dem Bass64. Müsste zugeben.
Ich kann ich meine ich darf alles hier drinne machen. Ich darf nur ich darf nur keine Double
Quotes verwenden. Mit Jason. Also wenn. Ne das funktioniert nicht. Ich Double Quotes
darf ich wegen der Config nicht nehmen und Single Quotes darf ich deswegen hier drinne
nicht nehmen. Und das hier geht schon wird schon einmal. Also im Prinzip würde so funktionieren
aber das macht halt meine Config nicht mit. Ok Moment Moment ähm. Warte mal warte mal
ich bin. Ja ok alles klar. Dump. Das ist gut. Import Jason Jason Dumps. Ok also. Ähm.
Import. Hast du deine Taskbar die wir nicht sehen. Ne welche Fenster hier. Ich hab mehrere
Desktops. Ich hab auch noch ein Winnerslauf wenn du das haben willst. Import. Jason. Oh
es ist noch Defined. Ja ja schon ok schon ok schon ok. So 1 2 3. Ach ne sollte das jetzt
nicht eigentlich was ausgeben. Sollte das nicht eigentlich was ausgeben. Oder muss ich
da vorher noch ein Print machen. Geht das sonst nur so. Ah ja ok. So weil da könnte
ich jetzt ja ich mein ich will ich will. Message. Ich will ja eigentlich das da im Endeffekt
haben. So. Das heißt das ist das ist ein Objekt. Mit. Gibt es hier sowas wie Message. Ah shit.
Ok ne dann hab ich keine Ahnung. Dann bleib ich jetzt dann bleib ich jetzt bei der Base
64 Geschichte. Wobei der Oberfläche die Taskbar ist nirgendwo. Gibt keine Taskbar. Brauchst
auch keine Taskbar. Du hast einen Desktop mit einem Browser und ein Desktop mit einem Terminal.
Und du kannst neue Programme starten wenn du willst. Aber ansonsten mehr mehr hast du
nicht. Was mein was. QnArcMessage. Ok. What. Ah ja ok. Take you. Alter. What.
Minus Minus ArcMessage. Minus. Das ist das. Ok. Das ist das. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ist ist nice.
Das müsste funktionieren. Nee funktioniert nicht. Es funktioniert doch nicht. Hier drinnen
können wir keine Single Quotes verwenden. Kann man. Ok. Echolull. So. Kann man das jetzt
an der Stelle hier blub. Kann ich es an der Stelle es capen. Weil so wird es nicht funktionieren
geschehen. Geht das. Geht das es capen. Nee das geht nämlich nicht. Weil man Single Quotes
in Single Quotes nicht es capen kann. Aber ich kann. Ich kann das hier es capen. Aha.
Ok. Zack. Probier mal. Probier das doch mal aus. Ok. Das könnte funktionieren. Das
könnte funktionieren. Ich bin mir nur bei einer Stelle nicht ganz sicher. Wie das TMAX
Zeug umgeht mit Backslash und es capen. Also vielleicht muss ich es hier auch doppelt
oder dreifach es capen. Backslash es capen. Wir werden es gleich sehen ob es funktioniert.
Ich ich ich ich fürchte dass es nicht dass es nicht klappt. Weil weil das weil er hier
mit dem mit dem Backslash irgendwelche Schmerzen hat. Dann müssen wir es vielleicht triple
triple es capen. Das wäre möglich. Fuck. No Closing Quotation. Ach so. Moment. Ich
bin ja auch doof. Es ist ja immer noch Bash minus C. So. So. Es ist kein Single Quote
zu viel. Ist kein Single Quote zu viel. So ist es richtig. Geht das jetzt so? Ok das
funktioniert. Mir persönlich reicht der Timer von der Minute aus. Oh Fuck. Es ist 22.12.
So spät schon. Bad Good Time jetzt gleich. Gleich ist es gleich. Bad Good Time.
Oh. Kam was? Kam was? Kam nix. Hat nicht funktioniert. Kam nix. Hat nicht funktioniert.
Ok wollen wir mal kurz zack zack. Wollen wir mal kurz testen. Das könnte wiederum funktionieren.
Weil der erste Escape geht ins Leere weil es von der Konfig kommt. Der zweite Escape landet
in der Shell und es capet dann beim Ausführen. Das könnte jetzt funktionieren. Also triple
triple Backslash. Mir wird schon noch was einfallen Leute. Wofür ist denn dieses ARX
Named? Warum ist es Dollar ARX Named? Wo ist da der Sinn? Also was ist wenn ich das weg
mache? Oh geht nicht. Ok. Wofür ist ARX Named? Achso das ist das hier dann der Name wie die
Binance soll er einsetzen. Es hat funktioniert Leute. Es hat funktioniert. Hier es geht triple
escape easy. So Moment jetzt brauchen wir noch eine Sache. Bell Emoji. Oh Bell Emoji.
Und hier wo A steht kommt ne Glocke rein. Klicken wir nochmal den Timer. Und jetzt müsste
eigentlich. Alter ich muss ins Bett Leute. Ich muss ins Bett. Jetzt müsste eigentlich
noch sich das irgendwie resetten oder so. Leute wisst ihr was? Weißt du was viel einfacher
wäre? Was viel easy also deutlich einfacher wäre anstatt so ein Scheiß zu machen? Einfach
ein Popup. Einfach ein stinknormales Popup machen. Was aufgeht und dann drinnen steht
die. Hallo Timer ist abgelaufen. Einfach sich diesen kompletten Blödsinn hier sparen.
Ne ne ne ich meine Popup im Original zeigt das dann einfach nur Break an. Ne Notifysend
funktioniert nicht ich hab kein Notify Zeug laufen. Hab ich auch nicht vor. Bäm Leute
bim bim. Und wenn ich es jetzt resette passiert halt nichts. Ist immer noch da. Das ist doof.
Müssen wir jetzt quasi noch mitbekommen wenn es. Also man könnte zum Beispiel. Wie heißt
das? Irgendwie so heißt das Ding glaube ich. Ne. Anti oder. Ach du Scheiße. Okbesh GTK.
Wie heißt dieses Ding? Jatt. Ne. Warte mal. Wie heißt dieses Ding für Popups zu machen?
Zenity. So. Das könnte man machen. Da kann man nämlich sowas machen in der Richtung.
Ich glaube Minus Minus Info. Bäm. All Updates are complete. Genau. Dann kommt da sowas kein
Minus Minus Text. Ich glaube es gibt auch Warning. Ja Warning. Minus Minus Text. Brauch
mal nichts. Kein Text. So Timer kann man da reinschreiben. Timer. Timer. Dann muss man
auf Ok klicken. Ja das ist gut das man auf Ok klicken muss. Wenn ich nämlich mal weg
bin und der Timer ist abgelaufen. Also. Ok Leute ich mach mal diesen Krampen da oben
weg. Das ist. Das ist mies. Also man könnte doch jetzt einfach sagen Besh Minus C. Zack
Zack. Das da. Und. Jetzt wenn ich das in Background schicke. So. Das muss doch funktionieren.
Ah ne ok. Und das quasi jetzt ausführen und dann. Dann geht ein Popup auf. Weil. Weil.
Also warum. Also warum ich mich gefreut habe dass da ein Timer drin ist. Ist folgendes.
Wenn ich duschen bin abends. Gehe ich. Raus und setze mich vor den PC. Wenn ich fertig
bin macht das Fenster auf. Und ich vergesse auch im Winter öfters das Fenster zuzumachen.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich könnte einfach hier den Timer einstellen standardmäßig
auf keine Ahnung 5 Minuten oder so. Und ich drücke den Timer und dann geht ein Popup auf
und ich weiß ok das kann nur das Fenster sein. Allerdings bevor wir jetzt unser eigenes
Notification System programmieren. Könnte man eigentlich auch irgendeine Notification
Demon verwenden. Ja. Muss man nicht dafür verwenden für alles. Für alles irgendwas
was 5 Minuten ist. Bam guck hier Timer. Nice. Funktioniert schon mal. Ok Leute jetzt aber
echt Badge-Time. Nee ich will keine Notification Demon ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich habe ein bisschen
rumgebastelt wieder. Zwar ziemlich ziemlich unsinnig. Marco Linux GitHub. Was ist das?
Wayland Notification kann ich nicht verwenden. Das ist ja kein Wayland. Ok Leute wir sehen
uns. Bis morgen machts gut. See you.